This is Jocko podcast number
one 54 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening and we are going to
go into some Q and a today. Sure.
We've got a bunch of
questions to go through.
I asked if anyone on Twitter had
questions and I got a ton of them so we're
going to try and answer some of them.
Some people if you're listening and you
asked a question like what time do I go
to bed or what kind of workout
do I do or something like that,
then I'm not going to answer
it now because I've answered
a bunch of other times.
There's a lot of fundamental things or
it's in the discipline equals freedom
field manual or you know.
So these were some questions
that had some of them yeah,
that we've heard some of them before.
Maybe there's a different spin, but um,
some of them I tried to pull back or
pull out the fresher type questions for
this and ones that aren't entirely fresh.
I'll try and cover very briefly with
whatever the new sort of angle is because
there is, there is a fact that, you know,
you go to a class and you learn two or
three new moves in Jujitsu and that's
good,
but you also review just to just to
arm lock and that is still beneficial,
especially if it's from a new angle or
a new instructor. They tell you, hey,
you know,
you move your hand a little bit further
out on their wrist if you're going for
that thing and it helps you. Sure. So
there's little little details. Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. So let's rock and roll.
Cool. All right. First question,
can you describe how difficult or no
factor leaving your family was before
deployment? I hate leaving. Okay. Let
me just answer that one. Yeah, it sucks.
Leave your family before deployment.
That's the way it is.
One thing that I've always said is, you
know, two guys that were saying, oh,
I got it, I'm gonna leave my kids and
it's horrible to leave. And I'm like, Yup,
it is. And they worry about
it from the kids' perspective.
I'm not going to be around, you
know, well, here's the deal.
Men have been leaving to go and fight
wars and do what they gotta do for
thousands of years.
And so your kids are going
to be okay and what good is,
they will see what you're doing,
see your service and your sacrifice and
you stepping up and holding the line for
the nation.
And that will be a lesson that
they will learn by observation.
And so even they'll be sad.
But inside they're learning.
They're learning that there's
things more important than yourself.
And so it's a good lesson
to be taught. A yes. Is it,
is it horrible to leave your family?
It sure is.
But it is a lesson for your kids and it
is a sacrifice you're making for your
country. And there is,
there are benefits to it. You know, your,
you get to come home and you'll see
and you'll see your kids, you know,
be all excited and it's good. It's a
good thing. So that's question one. Yes,
it's harsh, but it's a
worthy, it's a worthy cause.
Yeah.
A kind of second part to the question,
did you cry when you learned that your
childhood friend committed to the side
while you were doing that?
But, okay. Yeah,
so I mentioned that on a couple of
podcasts ago that my friend Jeff killed
himself while I was going through buds.
He was a kid I'd grown up with, but I had,
I had grown apart from him in
the later grades, sixth, seventh,
eighth grade into high school. We kind of
grew apart. Uh, so I did not, you know,
I was, you know, I was, I was sad
by the situation, but I didn't,
I wasn't super emotional
about it because I, we had,
we had kind of grown apart
and it had been, you know, I
was now in the navy, so, no,
didn't, uh, cry, but was definitely
a sad about the situation.
It didn't, I mean, kind of back to
that first part, but leaving, um,
is it like that, like a healthy dose of
that, like good for the kids? For sure.
Because it's like now they
know how to make, do you know,
like if dad's there for every little
thing kind of thing. Sure. Um, and then,
you know, the, the inevitable day comes
that you're going to go, you know,
leave or the air, at least
they got to leave. You know,
you don't have to depend on
kind of dead being there.
The trials and tribulations and,
and those things,
adversity will make kids tougher.
That's just the bottom line.
So this is a adversity and it's an
adversity that kids, you know, they,
they don't make them tougher. Make him
stronger. Yes. Agree. Next question.
Any good recommendations
for cutting back on alcohol?
Um, you know, just straight up. Why,
why would you cut back and not just
stop? At this point in my life, I don't,
I don't drink anymore.
Um,
and I know that some people
have an alcohol problem and
so I think trying to cut
back if you have an alcohol problem isn't
a realistic thing to do because you'll
take that slippery slope
and, and just get drunk. Uh,
so I think what you
have to do is just stop.
And I know that. And again, I, I, I'm not,
I don't,
I don't have a good familiarization to
know what it's like to be addicted to
alcohol. I didn't even, I didn't
even really like consciously,
oh I'm going to stop drinking now.
I just stopped drinking
because I was out of the navy.
I was working a bunch and carrying
on and wasn't around those, you know,
my bros anymore where we'd
go out and have a beer.
And so if that's not happening,
then it's not happening.
And that's one thing I'll say is I know
that people that have alcohol issues,
addictions, they always say
you got to change the people,
places and things that you do. So
the, that you hang around with, I like
to drink.
You can't hang around with them.
The place that you go where
everyone likes to drink,
you can't go to those places.
The things that you like to
do that involve drinking,
you can't do those things.
So there you go.
I would say stop drinking and hey,
if you're an alcoholic,
you got to get medical supervision cause
that's actually you can die if you're
an alcoholic and you stopped
drinking. Yeah. So you have to,
you have to like go and
get help. Uh, but stop.
Yeah.
A lot of those times,
those people who are that far into
alcoholism where they stopped drinking and
they die, that's like usually they
don't even want to stop drinking.
Usually that's just how
I'm drinking usually.
But I think I might have more
experience in this one than you,
but all those things, I mean that's
like a really concise in, in, in uh,
it's, that's a good way to put, to put
it like the people placing and things,
right. Activities, whatever.
Um, but a big part of it,
and I said this before where a big
part where I would stop drinking,
it was way easier when I just understood
what it was, you know, like understood.
Like what,
why am I just wanting to drink and
why is it that when I start drinking,
like it's kind of harder to stop,
you know?
Then maybe at another next guy
or whatever. And then when I,
once I understood like what's
happening physiologically or whatever,
I came up with my own little strategy
and the big part of it was like, Oh yeah,
like my brain is like tricking me into
thinking like, yeah, that you want this,
this thing or whatever.
That was like a major one and the other
one was kind of has to do with the
people placing things. It was um,
where if I had a reason not to drink,
like if I had a workout that I really
took seriously the next day or if I was
going to record or something dude to
do something where to be hung over or
whatever would really mess me up.
Um, it'd be way easier, you know,
so back like, you know, in high,
not high school, but in college,
like in athletics and stuff like that,
you never really drink during the week
cause he had practice the next day.
You don't want to be hung over and
practice, you know, so it'd be real easy.
Oh yeah,
I'm going to drinking today kind of thing.
So if you can kind of set up your life
where you have like something important
that you can kind of look forward to
and really care about the outcome of
something that's not necessarily mundane
and you're in your mind because a lot
of times that'll kind of, it's a
slippery slope when you're like, yeah,
it's important, but it's mundane
in your life. You'd be like,
let's see how I can endure it kind
of hung over. It's kind of worth it.
I'll pay the price now, you
know kind of thing. But yeah,
if you can set up your life where you,
you have something that you find like
important to be functioning fully that
helps Jujitsu train Jujitsu on Saturdays.
Yeah,
it affected me when I was in the teams
and we'd go out and drink it on Friday
and then when I started training
Jujitsu all the time, I didn't want to,
I wanted to be good to go
for Jujitsu. Sorry. Yeah,
I just like started started to stop
drinking on Friday nights hard.
I would see this with Jujitsu. I would
say compete in Jujitsu then because,
and I don't know, people are
different. You, there's a
spectrum, but to me, did you,
I mean I'll train hung over do you do to,
in fact you did.
So the helps the hangover if you
can drag yourself out of the house,
which is actually isn't that hard
once you do it once, if you go,
if you're hung up and you're like, oh
man, I really don't feel like right now,
but you just do it the first time
you do it, that's the hardest time.
Every other time you're like, yeah,
I did this before. This is easy.
I'm not going to be suffering.
You Go, you know, depending on,
depending on the level of hangover you're
going to suffer in Jujitsu or maybe
not after a while you get used to
it. I don't know, maybe sweating.
I was training like at
a higher level and I,
I mean like [inaudible] not trying
to be like a jerk, but like I would,
this is back when I was training train
with Fabio and so dean and I would show
up when we trained for like three
hours straight and like hard.
And so if you're going to come
in and do four rounds, yeah,
you're a little hung over,
it's no big deal.
But if you're going to come in and
you're going to train for, for, you know,
an hour worth of class, then you're
going to roll hardcore for for two hours.
You're not going to trust me.
You're not going to want to be all hung
over dehydrated and jacked up mentally.
Yeah, I dig it. And if you're
going to train fat hard, then yeah,
don't you probably.
It's going to be hard to drink.
That's your typical person is
not going to train that hard.
I mean probably because they're drinking
too much. If your competitor, no,
even people who don't drink don't train
that hard. Typically in my experience,
I don't know. But if you're training
for a tournament, it's going to,
you didn't take it way more seriously,
just kinda in the back of your mind,
you know, it's not just like, oh,
did you use the training? So again,
I'm not saying that's not gonna work if
you're just practicing so it won't work.
I'm not saying that,
I'm saying people are different.
And if I use myself as an example,
like I could, I could train,
I could hang a brows I was training
with like when I'd go train,
like at autos or whatever with
these crazy training sessions. Yeah,
it would go slightly hungover.
Go Dean every Friday. So,
okay, look, of course I could
probably train better if,
if I didn't drink the night before
for sure, but I'm just saying as a,
as a catalyst for stopping drinking,
that didn't help you.
It didn't help me as much as it
me. Yeah. And it didn't even,
it wasn't even like a catalyst
to help me stop drinking.
It was just the functionality
of life. Yes, it was, oh,
I've got to do this in the morning.
Cool.
I'm not going to get all hammered tonight
so I can do better as a human. Yeah.
And that's really the format right there
where you find something. I mean to me,
you know, like you're not like Jujitsu,
just the training. If I wasn't,
if I was competing, oh, I'd
easily stopped drinking easily,
but just for the train, if I didn't have
a competition or whatever, it wasn't,
it wasn't,
it didn't help as much as one might think.
But if I had something like, you
know, if we're recording or something,
something that you would think
you might be able to even,
it just depends on how important it is
for you to be functioning at the best
self that you can. You know, if I get
tapped out a few more times in Jujitsu,
it's kind of like, hey, whatever.
So it just depends on who
you are is what I'm saying.
Either way. Yeah, man. I think that
helps, but that's going to be hard. Um,
either way if you don't have some kind
of like format scaffolding in your brain
to like a plan, you know, like a
little strategy to be like, yeah,
I'm just going to drink less. Just
cut. I'm just going to drink less.
Like it's pretty rare that that's
going to, yeah, it's going to,
it's going to work. That's where I cut
back. I said don't cut back to stop. Yeah.
Jack,
next question.
Communication is often used as
an excuse both under and over.
Oh, under communication and
over communication for why
the direction isn't clear.
Any suggestions on balancing comms,
communication up and down with
the right level of detail?
Here's a jacked up answer.
The answer to this question of
how to balance comms is comps.
You want to balance communications.
You have to communicate.
You have to understand,
hey,
do you guys know what's going on and you
need to check and make sure that they
know what's going on. If they know what's
going on, great. If they don't know,
then you didn't communicate
with them enough.
If you spend too much time communicating
and and now they're looking at you with
a blank stare like, hey bro, we got this.
Then you communicated too
much so and ask them, Hey,
do you understand what's
going on? Cool. And if not,
do you understand why we're doing what
we're doing? Cool. All right, good.
I'm going to let you go do it now.
So the answer to making sure you're not
communicating either too much or too
little is communication. I hate to
say that, but that's what it is.
There can be some of that can be
nonverbal communication. You know,
you can observe if you,
if you give your guys a task and then
you go out and observe them and you see
that they can execute it really well,
then you'd know that you've done a
good job communicating it to them.
If you go out to observe them and they
don't know what they're doing and they
don't know what's going on,
then you realize how I didn't
give them enough information.
I need to communicate more.
So you don't have to necessarily ask them.
You can tell through observation and
checking on them and seeing where they're
at and what they're doing,
if they actually understand
what's going on. So yeah,
that's, that's it. Pretty straightforward.
Get you a little feedback loop going.
Yeah, that, but it is kind of like, and
I'm going to use the word again, dance.
It is kind of like a dance. It's
a dichotomy. Yes you can. Yes,
you can communicate too much and you can
communicate too little and you have to
find the balance thing because
if you communicate too much,
people stop listening to you and then
it's no longer communication at that point
because it's kind of like if you're
sleeping and I'm like, Hey, okay,
Jocko telling you what to do.
Like you can't hear me.
It's not going into your brain. It kind
of has to go in. Your brain kind of does.
You got to catch what I'm throwing then,
you know,
and vice versa if we're quote
unquote communicating. So yeah,
you to put quotes around the
word. Well, there you go.
But if, if, if one of those,
even one of those things isn't
happening and we're technically,
we're not communicating. So like the
whole over thing that's like, yeah,
someone talking too much and the
other guy stops listening or you over
communicate so far in the spot.
I'm just saying like how you say
like feedback, you know like that
that's an important thing because
if you're like blah blah blah blah.
And how you say the blank
stare communications con
communications not going on
anymore. Yeah, like the one that, I
don't know. You're giving me feedback,
which is good. See what I'm
saying? So now I'm clear.
I'm clear that you want me to move
it along. See what I'm saying?
It's good communication on your part.
Here's the thing with you and
your blank stare in my experience,
which I have a lot,
by the way,
your blank stare communicates way
more than just like a blank stare
for real. Mike Cirelli would, will
tell you all about that. Like you'll,
you'll have a whole conversation with
me and not even say one single word for
real.
I know exactly what you're saying.
See like right now I know exactly what
you're saying. Anyway, next question.
That's exactly what I was
saying. Actually. Like I said,
when taking ownership,
how can you prevent your boss thinking
you're a complete screw up and stop it
from escalating to a point where there,
where he starts blaming you for
things you're not actually at fault.
So this is one of those catch 22
situations where you actually don't think
you're at fault. So when you
actually don't think you're at fault,
then you're thinking, oh,
I'm just taking ownership.
So that that's like the cool thing to do.
And that's what I'm trying to use this as
to make, to improve my situation. Right?
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna quote unquote take ownership.
And when you quote on quote,
take ownership,
but you actually don't believe
you're at fault, then you're not,
you're not really taking ownership.
So when you look around at your mission,
at your tasks, like what you're
being told to do and you say, Oh,
I've got to do this thing.
Oh it didn't go right and I'm going to
take ownership of it and get it fixed.
If you're just saying that and
you don't actually mean it,
then your boss starts blaming you for it.
Well if you,
you should feel that way. Cause when
your boss blames you for something,
you know what you should be saying.
Yeah boss,
I know I said that this was
my responsibility and this
is what I'm going to do
to fix it. You shouldn't, when your
boss starts blaming for you for things,
you shouldn't say, well no actually
that's not my area of responsibilities.
What you should say is, Oh
yes boss, like I just said,
this is my fault and here's what I'm
gonna do to fix it. That's what you do.
So you actually think
about this when you're,
when you're the type of person
that takes ownership of things,
you actually can't get blamed for things.
You can't blame me for things cause I'm
already volunteering and saying that
this was my responsibility. I'm going
to fix it. So that's what you do.
That's what you do. You take ownership
and you take real ownership at,
which means when there's a problem,
you look at it and say, this is, hey,
this is my fault and here's
what I'm going to do to fix it.
And when your boss says, Hey,
yeah, this is your fault, you go,
I know boss, I know 100% and this
is what I'm gonna do to fix it,
then you go fix it. Yeah. And
the thing that I didn't notice,
I said this before too, but I think
it's easy to sort of forget when,
especially if you're thinking like
this, which is, which I dig it, man,
is the whole, what am I going to
do to fix it? Because when you,
when you like for Real, uh, take
ownership of whatever, it's because man,
just like I said, it's almost like
what you just said, where, where you,
where you say you can't blame me,
blame me,
because I already took her
responsibility kind of thing because,
and in a big way,
it's not necessarily about blame,
it's more about fixing problems that are
still on a come up. Nothing's perfect,
you know? So now it's like, it's more of
like a, a way of dealing with problems.
Lesson, a whole blaming,
taking blame thing in culture,
in business, in real life will blame
each other. That's what happens.
And if you're the person that
says, Hey, you know what?
This is actually my fault and this
is what I'm going to do to fix it.
There you go. Yeah. Then that blame you
could say, yeah, blame me. I'm just,
I'm the guy because that's not the guy
made this mistake. No factor. Yeah. Yeah.
And then you can just focus on
fixing the problem and Yemen,
and that's the thing is the reason I bring
it up is because it is easy to forget
that part because that blame is still
the problem part with extreme ownership.
I mean, up here obviously, because it's
like, hey, I took him extreme ownership.
Like, why are you saying
it's my fault? Yeah. Yeah.
It's a good or bad.
That's not the main part.
The main part is like you got to fix
it. Yeah. Anyway, yeah, I think so.
All right. Next, next question.
I have to warrior kid daughters who were
very much on the path with pretty much
everything, but snacking, they're sick,
they're starting to put
some weight on as a result,
despite tons of physical activity
and good eating at mealtime.
How can I coach them in this area
without being overbearing? I would say,
I don't have snack food in your house.
That's junk, which you probably do don't.
And yeah, that's, that's real simple.
Where are they going to do if
there's no snack food in house?
Are they going to snack? Yeah. The
answer is they're not because there's,
they can go out and eat grass
yard if they're still hungry.
But, uh, so that's, that's one thing. The
other thing is you gotta be careful with,
with kids,
and I'll say this with girls especially,
you start throwing that like, hey,
you need to watch your weight.
You can really mess with their body image.
So you gotta be really careful about
what you're doing with a kid with a,
with a little girl, cast what
little girls, little boys guest,
what they are when they're,
when they're little.
The little pudgy little creatures,
you know,
and I'm sure there'll be
some genetic kids that are,
have 2% body fat and a 12 pack of
abs when they're six years old in.
But most kids are like little,
little bit pudgy. That's part of,
they're prepping for their growth spurt.
And if you're all freaked out about it,
um, you know, just you,
what you're gonna do is you're
gonna put that in their head,
they're gonna start looking in the mirror
and you don't want to do that to your
kids. So don't have any junk food
snacks in the house. Give him some milk.
Right?
Give him some more your kid milk cause
it tastes delicious and it is like a
snack and it's good for them.
And it'll be, it'll be satiating.
I know you don't like that Word Echo,
but it will satiate them.
It'll make them feel full. So
that's, that's a kind of snack
food to have in the house.
And if you're going to have other
snack food than make it beef Jerky,
make it some healthy, you know, some
carrots, some som celery, you know,
make it some good healthy
stuff. But um, yeah,
like worrying about your kids starting
to put on some weight when they're,
I don't know how old they are in this
particular case, but just be careful.
You don't want to, you don't want to
freak your kids out and get them with a,
with a really paranoid body image.
Especially girls,
they're getting it from a
million different directions
and you gotta be careful
with it because that's a real,
that can be turned into a real problem.
And the thing that actually I,
you clarified really good to me one day
where when you kind of implement change,
you know, in a routine, especially if
snacking is kind of like a routine audit,
when you implement change, like it's,
there's going to be some hiccups there.
You know, like whether it be, I don't
know in this case like complaining like,
hey well you know, you're, you're saying
hey, don't keep snacks in the house.
So now there's no chocolate covered
pretzels anymore. You know like hey,
I remember the chocolate covered pretzels,
they were right there in the little
pantry right there. Now they're gone.
Like what up? I haven't seen him
in dates. Yeah. You're like, hey,
we're not doing the chocolate
covered pretzels anymore or whatever.
There's going to be some blow back there.
Especially from the little kids,
you know, they can be, look what dad and
you know, there might be some complaining.
So I think if we go in or when
we go in knowing those things,
that helps a lot. So you're kind
of prepared for it, you know,
you can kind of plan what you're
going to say. Are you going to have,
you're getting way too intense with this,
but there's no chocolate covered pretzels.
Guess what?
They didn't have him at the store. I'm not
getting them. They're bad for us. Yeah,
I'd eaten a dig it. But a lot of
times when you have, you know,
two girls or whoever,
he's good get a bar. Yeah.
But they're not just your kids
that I pull up bar train. Yeah.
But they're not going to be like, Hey,
oh whoa, no chocolate pretzels. Oh,
I'll just do pullups. It doesn't work like
that with the little kids. You got it.
Not that big of a deal to take, to pull
a snack out of your house. I don't think.
Especially if you get some beef jerky
and you're like, ah, you know what,
that's us bad for us and I
don't want to eat any more.
So I got some beef jerky here. It's really
good. Taste it. Yes. But to get seaweed,
dried seaweed used to eat that stuff.
Like it was like they were damn octopuses.
But that's good though, right by. Yes.
I liked the dry seaweed.
Yeah,
it sells pounding some of that the
other day with both of my kids,
they're like salty delicious.
Anyway,
what I'm saying is I'm not saying
necessarily make it a huge deal.
I'm just saying if you're ready
for the blow back, you know,
cause what if you're not ready?
You think that, okay, I'll,
I'll agree with you just to do,
we can move this conversation along in
order to prep for huge stop the chocolate
covered in your compound, you don't really
agree with, you can come up with a, uh,
a plan of action, little uphill, a plan
of action and immediate action drill.
When that six year old goes, dad, where
are the chocolate covered pretzels?
You have a very well rehearsed response.
You can do some role playing
with your wife and you can go,
yeah, see I see what you're doing.
Then you're cool man. I'm telling you,
this helps.
This will help because you know the,
the poor kids you care, you know, you
care about the short term a little bit,
you know,
of course the long term,
you know that's what you're doing.
The whole thing are you going to do
is explain, hey, you know what, hey,
we're not doing that anymore because it's
not good for us. Oh, okay. Straight up.
Cool. There it is. That's
not a huge well, well
anyway, roleplay with
your wife. Next question,
why isn't MMA or did you do to a bigger
component of law enforcement training?
It seems to be a huge missed opportunity.
Yeah,
it certainly is a huge missed opportunity.
I,
I plead with all law enforcement
personnel to train Brazilian Jujitsu,
MMA, wrestling, boxing, Moy,
Tai as much as you possibly can and I
plead with law enforcement agencies of all
types that I talk to to get these types
of programs in your departments because
there is no doubt that it will help you,
help your officers be better and more
prepared to handle situations on the
street.
Just had a police officer coming here the
other day that was just signing up and
you know,
she just got done to the police academy
and I'm so thankful that she's here
because I'm like,
yes,
go and start training immediately and
it will be so beneficial for you in your
career,
in your life.
And one thing about all these things and
any form of martial arts for like self
defense or self defense
situations or you know,
because that's sometimes when it turns
into a for a police officer there,
there are no longer,
you know,
once you things things crossover from
where they're on offense to where they're
on defense. And for a police
officer, this is a great example,
like this was a female and hey could a
female hundred and 18 pound female police
officer take a guy that was drunk,
slightly drunk,
a wrestler who's 240 pounds?
The answer is no, she's not going
to fare well in that situation.
But if she knows if whatever she knows,
if she knows if she's trained,
she might be able to prolong that conflict
long enough for her backup to arrive.
She might be able to stay alive, keep
control of her gun or whatever, you know,
keep control of the situation
long enough that she,
that she will get her back up there.
So that right there,
that's the same thing I tell uh, females
that want self defense. It's like,
hey look,
I'm not saying you can't cause you look
at some of our female Jujitsu players,
they will choke out a
dude deflect straight up.
They will arm walk them like for
real and a 200 pound wrestler,
they'll put a guillotine on them and choke
them, put them asleep. So that's that.
That can happen.
That's what someone that's really skilled
to make up for their lack of strength
and lack of size being a female.
But what if even if you're not
that good but you can postpone,
you can prolong someones trying to
grab you and take you somewhere.
Someone's trying to do something
to you. You can prolong it. If the,
the longer you can delay the, the, uh,
or offense from taking place,
the better chance you have of somebody
else coming along or somebody noticing or
that person just giving up because
most, most criminals are, you know,
weak minded and they don't want that
kind of resistance. So yes, totally. Um,
you're asking why isn't it, there's a
bunch of reason or reasons why it isn't.
And one of them, and I've talked
about this before, but there was,
there's been cases where people
that were not trained enough,
they were trained enough to be dangerous,
where they've choked guys to death.
And that has happened.
You crush someone's wind pipe,
you can be screwing around and, or
you just not screwing around, but you,
you can be, you can be screwing around.
You could, you know, you and I could,
could start wrestling around.
If you and I were white belts and
we started going out it really hard,
there's a chance one of us could
get the other one in a choke hold,
had a couple drinks in us. And
next thing you know, um, um,
I put you to sleep, which is, Oh
yeah, I'm going to put you sleep.
Cause sometimes you choke
your friend. You're like, I'm
going to put you to sleep.
Well,
if I'm drunk and you're drunk and I put
you to sleep and I don't really know
that you're asleep yet and I'm
squeezing an extra hard cause I'm drunk.
Next thing you know,
I look up and all of a sudden your
hyoid bone is crushed your windpipe and
you're not going to die.
So that's happened in law enforcement.
They've banned chokes, which is a
horrible thing because choking is, uh,
is one of the best and most minimal forces
to use to subdue someone is to choke
them. Even an arm lock is
going to break their arm.
It's going to ruin their tendons.
It's going to hurt him.
A choke doesn't even hurt someone. It just
puts him to sleep just capacities. So,
but that's one of the reasons
why they don't teach it as much.
The other reason is they don't give enough
training to law enforcement officers
and they need to, uh, they train. Uh,
an absolutely pathetic amount of time
in what they call defensive tactics.
Generally the police officers',
call it defensive tactics,
which is them fighting and maintaining
weapon retention and all that they train
of,
of very small number of hours a year.
They measure the time that they
train in, in, in a year, in hours.
That's how little they train. So my, my,
my campaign I'd like to go forward with
is I think that police officers who
spend one fifth of their
active duty time training,
one fifth of their time should be
training. That's the way it should work.
And I don't know how I'm going to
start that ground wave, but there's,
that's such a solid idea that
no one can argue against it.
There's not one single argument against
every police officer spending one fifth
of their time training. And, and if
you want to argue with me about that,
and the argument is,
well, we won't have enough police
officers out on the beat then.
And here's the question back at that,
would you rather have
eight highly qualified,
highly trained officers out on the beat
or 10 officers that were barely trained
at all? And the answer is so easy to that
question. So that's a a bunch of things.
I'll continue to push
that as much as I can.
And I know a ton of law enforcement
people listen to this and just, you know,
I think that's a great idea to
start pushing from the ground,
from the grass roots.
We want to one fifth of our time training,
it's gonna make us all better.
It's going to prevent,
think of all the time that's all hours
that are wasted in legal actions after
there is a bad shooting or an
injury or something like that.
Think of all the stuff
that gets wasted there.
Take the officer's and train
them properly. That's what,
that's what needs to happen.
So hopefully it will.
And then what would you suggest that,
I mean kind of obvious what you can
say, but he's like, just like, you know,
police officers going and getting
training on their own. So like, you know,
if you have to go get
training on your own,
go get training on your own
because most of you did,
some places they'll have
a law enforcement. Yeah.
Some kind of deal. Yeah.
Actually this Guy Craig,
right. And now me the
police officer up in Oregon,
if I'm not mistaken,
always doing Jujitsu with his
uniform on and you can look,
look him up on Instagram. You can see
all the stuff he does with Jujitsu.
Any applies that to law enforcement and,
and it like men,
it's such a clear demonstration of the
benefits and in, in, you know, whatever,
everyone who trains like,
you know, it's like man,
it becomes really after
you trained for a while,
all this dealing with other people
in chaotic situations. But it's easy.
It's literally easy. So man, yeah. Get,
watch Craig in his stuff. And,
and here's the thing though,
I don't know how that works with
like work and you know, hey,
you're at risk of injury. I
Dunno. I Dunno. I Dunno what
the whole deal is. But man,
the way I say it meant trends or Craig's
over there training all the time and so
yeah,
just train on your own until you're
situation arises with the law enforcement.
Yeah, well hopefully they will implement
that sometime in the future. Man.
Next question.
Bow or not in g a okay.
And Jujitsu. He's three months
in professor, not bowing.
I don't other practitioners bow.
No one told me when enrolling
versus I'm not in a herd.
Respect to professor
mats and practitioners.
This pretty simple question. Some
people bow when they all go on the mat,
some people bow to the professor,
some people don't. I don't.
I just kind of do whatever and
it doesn't really matter to me.
And there's a little bit of paranoia
in the question, which I understand,
which is like, hey, hey, when in Rome
do as Romans do, but at the same time,
you know, I'm going to hold the
line kind of on my personal value.
So it's like I don't, I'm not bowing.
Right. That's not my gig or I,
it's respect you got a,
like there's
both those extremes and both of them
can be articulated in a way that's fine.
And to me, I'm just like, whatever. Oh
everyone. It looks like everyone's bound.
Call him about not, not that big of a
deal. I don't, I don't freak out about it.
It's not that big of a deal.
I think it, to me, to me,
the overall arching
principle of my actions,
bowing or not bowing is more based on
my overall principle of not making a
spectacle out of myself
one way or the other.
Like I'm not here to like draw
attention and be like, hey, I don't bow.
Or Hey, this is Jujitsu. You need to
respect the that I'm like over here.
Just trying to train. Yeah. Not trying
to make a big deal out of myself.
So if everyone's bound, it's like, cool,
look, they know no big deal. I get it.
Or if no one's bowing and it's
like, Eh, no big deal. Yeah.
I guess people might be disappointed
if I don't have some hard stance.
Right? Yeah. But I don't, yeah, there's,
there's some things I don't worry about.
That's one of them. Yes. I believe
that. How about we just trade? Yeah,
agree and other that'll sort itself out
anyway because if you're at a school,
because some schools sorta required,
that's the protocol here at this school.
No big deal. You can have that
exact attitude be like, cool,
that's what we're doing.
That's what it could cause.
Some people you bought on the Mat,
you bought off the mat at the
beginning of class to the, you know,
to the picture of whatever at the end,
like the whole deal. But same deal.
It's like balance, not hard to
do. It doesn't like, you know,
affect your family life at home or
nothing like that. It's just, just bough.
Same thing with not bowing doesn't affect
your, yeah. It's not hard to know now.
I guess there's a line in
either direction right there.
You know where you could, you know,
you could be telling me like, okay,
when we bough, you need to bow
and you need to praise, praise,
praise instructor, whoever. It's
like, hmm, okay. Probably not.
I'm probably not going to do that.
You know, like we're, we're not,
we're not worshiping, right.
We're not bowing. It's like, okay,
little sign of respect. Cool. I got
that, but we're not going to turn uh, uh,
respect into a worship. There's a
line that that will not be crossed.
The other direction is like, oh, you know,
someone's teaching a class and
I'm just going to walk, you know,
run my mouth and walk onto the
mat. Like it's no big deal. No.
Like you're going to be respectful
to the instructor of course.
So I'm just going to find out a little
balance there and balanced those two
dichotomies.
So what if you go as a guest or
whatever and another place in their,
their protocol is in European,
like sorted,
crossed over to worship.
I have you going to,
I haven't really been to an
academy crossed over into worship.
Let's say it did just a little bit
or like would you go as a guest,
do you just go through the
motions at a respect for?
What I would probably do is go through
the motions but then do other actions
that would indicate to everyone that I
have a free mind and that I'm not down
with what they just did type of scenario.
Like I wouldn't be obnoxious about it,
but I'd be like,
Oh you know what I'm gonna do is take
off my g and sit on the mat right now.
Like oh that's not allowed.
Okay. Sorry. Cool. Oh my back.
Oh yeah, yeah, no big deal.
They put it on like, all
right, cool. Whatever.
It just kind of like indicate would you
say at my academy like we don't care
about these small pink.
Yeah. Maybe like, um,
I dunno if I do that cause
then you're just trying to do,
trying to again make a spectacle.
I'm not trying to make a spectacle man.
I'm just trying to, I'm just trying
to, just trying to be, you know,
just trying to get some training
in men to be honest with you.
So don't make a spectacle and get in the
way and let that Spec to go get in the
way of your training. Yeah. How
often are we making, I mean,
how often do people try and make
spectacles out of themselves?
It's like people do that and that's
not cool. Like don't do that.
Don't be a spectacle. Just be, you know,
I told a story before about the,
the,
when I went to University of San Diego
and there was a professor there that was
like push, she was an American,
but she was a Buddhist monk.
Right. You know, so she had it at
some point converted to Buddhism and,
and she would shave her head and walk
around in the robes and stuff like that.
And I was like, we don't, one
of the tenants of, you know,
being Buddhist is to like not
make a spectacle of yourself.
And yet here you are walking around
a Western campus in, uh, you know,
in a, in a uniform with a
shaved head. That's not,
that's not that you are making a
spectacle of yourself. So I was just like,
I would,
I would think it would be more like the
Buddha to just wear a pair of jeans and
a tee shirt and just have like,
whatever normal. Just be normal.
Just look as normal as
possible. Yeah, there's a whole,
like there's a whole thing that's
sort of my, that's sort of,
I fall into a live fall back
on that, you know, like a lot.
So you'd think that she might argue world,
this is how us Buddhists like minimalize
our whole efforts to have heavy duality
or whatever.
But at the end of the day,
you are when you're in Thailand, which
is awesome. Like the Buddhist monks,
if they're everywhere and they're
there, that's what they do, you know?
And so they're,
they're not making a spectacle
of themselves at all and
they come around and get
rice in the morning. It's very
cool. It's a very cool culture.
But if you're in a culture of a
southern California University,
there's no other Buddhist monks that
are walking around. So you're kind of,
and it may, maybe I'm wrong, you know,
I, I'm not trying to disparage, you know,
this individual, I'm just saying
from my perspective, I was like, hmm,
if you really want to have the,
the low profile and not bring
attention to yourself and give up,
you know,
give up the trappings of ego,
right.
You want to give up the trappings of ego,
then you don't want people to notice you.
If you don't want people to notice you,
you dress like a gray man. You just sucks.
I kind of normal, you know, forgettable.
Yeah.
So anyways,
I'm trying to get like deep into
the religious aspect of a Jujitsu
and robes.
Sure.
But that's just kinda my opinion.
I dig it. All right. Next question.
Did you ever have a CCT?
Did you ever have us CCT attached
to your unit? And if yes,
how was having them alongside and
what advantages did they bring to the
battlefield?
So CCT is an air force combat controller
and they're special operations guys.
They're awesome guys.
They go through really hardcore
training and I didn't really,
I worked with him occasionally,
not very directly on a couple occasions.
They were great guys,
but I never worked with them enough to,
to be talking about him all the time
cause I just didn't have that experience.
You know,
I don't talk about a bull riders
either cause I don't know many of them,
you know, so it's just, it's just
that, uh, but they're great guys.
I know they have an awesome reputation
and my friends have worked with them, uh,
loved working with them.
If there was a guy that was,
I've had a couple of guys a
kind of heard names of, so for,
as far as coming on the
podcast, yeah, of course.
I never formed on the podcast have
a without question. No problem.
And what we did,
what we had was we had Anglico,
which was Dave Burke and his guys.
They were the guys that were doing the
CCT type mission for us when we were in
Ramadi. So, uh,
that's one of the reasons why we
didn't work with them very much on that
deployment.
The previous deployment we had my,
I had my own jet attack and that's
what we work with. So just, just, uh,
just didn't have that opportunity.
So they're awesome guys though.
Next question.
Jocko.
Currently in a busy and stressed place
in life and keep looking back at what
could have been,
how do you bounce back to doing you
and not getting in your own head?
I appreciate what you and
I could do. Thank you both.
And God bless. All right. Uh,
you know,
we can look back all day long at what
could have been and it doesn't matter.
Well, the only thing that matters from
the past is what you learned from it.
So let's learn from it and look at
the future. And one thing I'll say is,
oh, well it's like this saying about
when's a good time to plant a tree?
Do you know when the best time
to plant a tree is right now?
Either 22 years ago or
right now, right? Like,
look, you didn't do it then. So we'd
guess what you can do. You do it now.
When's the best time to start a
savings account? Same deal. Yeah.
It's the same thing like you know,
20 years ago or right now.
So w w w if you sit there and say,
oh well I could have done,
if I wish I would have done this
years ago, I wish it well guess what,
you look up at a year and you don't have
that little sapling now you could have
a little sapling, right? Nothing.
So it's not that big of a deal.
Dave, hey you, you, you went through life.
You made some, you wasted some time. Good.
You didn't waste it completely.
First of all, you learned from it.
You've got to experience, you had
fun, you did other things you'd,
you learned about,
you learned about relationships because
some girl dumped you and you realize
that you can't over commit to a,
uh, to a liar. You know, he's like,
you've learned these things,
right?
So just because things were negative
experiences in the past and they didn't
feel good to go through,
it doesn't mean that they were all bad
cause you still took something away from
it and you learned from it.
So that's part one.
Part two is what are you going to do?
Plant a tree today.
That's what you're going to do.
Plant a tree today and start to nourish
that tree and take the lessons that you
learned to sprinkle on that tree and
feed that tree so we can grow fast.
That tree that you plant today should
be able to grow faster than the one you
would have planned it 20 years ago
because you have the knowledge on how to,
on how to nourish that tree and feed
that tree so it can grow quicker.
So just get on the path.
Don't,
don't play around with what's going on
in the past. Learn from it, move on.
Human Nick goes along with how like little
beach, it wasn't a speech, a little
talk you had with me about, you know,
you gotta play the long game or
whatever and kind of in this case,
same deal where it's kind
of more so than even play.
You are playing the long game but keep
the long game in mind cause that's what
you know, those thoughts
like Dang, I should've,
I should've went to college where I
should or shouldn't have to. I don't know,
whatever this whole what
could have been kind of deal.
That's like your mind saying like right
now, if I would have done that back then,
right now I would have this and that's
the part that kind of message like jams
you up mentally, right? Where you're like,
man, I could have had this right now.
So when you think so you don't,
you still as a result typically
in my experience anyway,
which was almost done, but
typically I think like wait, I,
because when I think of what could have
been because of this thing that I kind
of want right now,
I don't want to seed right now.
I want what I could have Hatton.
That's what I want to have that.
So plant the seed. Yeah. So, but ma
look kind of emotionally or mentally,
that's not where your mind is. Your
mind isn't like, Hey, I can't have that.
I accept that as.
So let's think of the future now
that your mind doesn't do that.
It's more like hung up on on that,
right? But what you don't have right now,
that empty void that you have,
you don't want to fill that void with a
seed. The seed doesn't do nothing for me.
The not even a sapling that doesn't
do anything. A full grown tree.
That's what I want right now.
That's what I could have had.
So how is a seed the problem
or the solution to my problem?
But if you're looking at the big picture,
the long game as you so
eloquently put it at day brother,
the seed is nothing but a
tree at a different time.
And that's really what it is.
See what I'm saying?
So that is a bra that is a solution.
So what I'm saying and then
be the most philosophically a bold and
and unbounded statement you've made on
this. The seed is nothing but a treat at
different times. I like how you did that.
Good job.
It's all been worth it.
The pain and suffering. Good
listening has finally paid off. Good.
Cool. Man. Thank you. Anyway, so yeah,
I think if like
can keep that long game in mind.
That's helped me
like a lot with just even like
small little things, you know stuff.
It's like uncomfortable.
I don't want to do this right now,
but you know this exact thought like,
man I am,
I'm looking forward to
the day that I'm not,
I'm thinking the opposite of what could
have been. I'm thinking now I'm thinking.
Sure. I'm so glad I planted that
seed last year or whatever, you know,
so you can look at the long game and
kind of fulfill all that stuff. Anyway,
next question. Hi Jocko. Echo my
name spelt wrong by the way here,
but hydrochloride echo,
quick question. I really get,
I get really bad anxiety doing
almost everything. For example,
when talking to people,
I always feel like as if I'm going to
say something stupid and this makes me
start to stutter and lose my train
of thought and I just go blank.
I'd say on that one, uh, first of all,
you got to condition yourself. You know,
you've got to practice, you've got to
rehearse. I would actually, first of all,
I would say go get some speech therapy
if someone to help you out because that
will,
that will be beneficial to you.
Getting someone that's a professional
to come in and say like, okay,
here's the drills that we're going to
do. A my buddy that drums in my band, he,
there's drumming drills that you can
do so you can get your left hand to do
something different than your left foot
and your right hand to do something.
There's drills that you can do to
overcome because if you're like me,
you're not a drummer.
I my right hand and right foot are going
to do the same thing at the same time.
My left hand and my left foot are going
to do the same thing at the same time,
but there's drills that you can do to
overcome that and there's drills that you
can do with speech so you can practice
and you rehearse and you think about it.
Then you'll get better at it.
And the cool thing is like once
you start to build some confidence,
then you get more and more confident
and you'll get better and better at.
The other thing I would say is talk
about things that you know, right?
Don't try and explain
things that you don't know.
Don't try and try and come up with some
theory that you don't understand and try
and just roll it out off the tip of
your tongue because you don't know it.
So just when that's happening,
just sit back and kind of formulate
your thoughts and think, okay,
if all the things I'm thinking right now,
what do I actually kind of have a grip on?
Maybe it's a question sometimes
forming something in a question,
we'll make it easier for you to
state it because you're saying, hey,
I got a question and now
you're not putting pressure
on yourself to come up with
this perfect yarn of why that this
theory that you out instead of you post
something as a question,
that'll take some pressure off you
and talk about things that you know.
And if you don't know it,
then ask a question about it and that'll
get you more comfortable and you keep
talking and keep trying and over time
you'll get better and better at it,
but yet you have to,
you have to not jump in like don't go
and volunteer to give the speech at the
local club. Right. No volunteer too.
When people are having a conversation
say, Hey, can I ask a question about this?
Start with that.
That's like the easiest entry point.
No one's expecting you to say anything.
Brilliant. When you ask a question,
they're just expecting you
to ask questions so it's
not that big of a deal and
then just build on that man. It's exposure
therapy, exposure therapy. That's okay.
Next question.
When you transitioned from e Oh,
how did your approach to working with
with men you previously served with as
enlisted now that you were an officer?
This is such an easy question because the
bottom line is when I transferred from
being an enlisted guy
to be being an officer,
I didn't change anything in the
way that I treated everyone.
I treated people the same.
And when I was a young enlisted guy or
a senior enlisted guy or more senior,
I was never like, I would, I only made
it to e five before I went off, sir.
But when I was in my third platoon with
other guys that were not in their third
platoon, I treat people like,
hey man, with, you know, hey,
this is what we're going to do. This is
how we're going to make it happen. Now,
I got to caveat that for the guys that
were in platoons with me when I was in
the e five mafia,
hey,
I was a little crazy with the hazing and
like does suck to be a new guy in one
of my opportunities and I get that.
But as you guys have told me,
you appreciate it. It once
you've got a little, you know,
once you saw the big picture, there
was appreciation, but no, from a,
from an actual working relationship,
hey, you know, what are you gonna do?
You gonna stay humble.
You're gonna treat people with respect
regardless of your above them or below
them in the chain of command.
Um,
there's this saying that I didn't talk
about when we had Derek Herrera on and
it's, it's pulled from that
speech by Jacqueline. Bye.
Gunnery Sergeant Jacqueline.
He says, at the end of the speech, he
says, I'm not above you, not below you,
always beside you. So think about
that from a leadership perspective,
not above you, not blow you always beside
you. So if you have that attitude, look,
I'm not a boat when I'm not
above you and I'm not below you,
like we're equals and we're trying to
figure out how to best solve this problem.
And if you treat people like that,
regardless if you're above them or
below them and the chain of command,
you'll treat him with respect
and humility, you'll be
fine. And that's what I did.
I didn't treat anybody any
different. And I mean, I had,
I had guys that worked for,
that worked for me,
that had been my peers or
that I had worked for before.
When I, when I went through that
transition and it was like no factor.
It was literally no factor
because these guys were, you know,
when we were friends,
we worked together.
We focused on getting the job done
when they were above me in the chain of
command,
what did I do?
I worked hard and focused on getting the
job done when they were below me in the
chain of command. Oh No. It's
like, hey, they're working hard.
Did they become less of a person? Did
I become more of a person? No. No.
I put a different rank on my sleeve.
What does that mean? Nothing.
It doesn't mean it mean. It means,
what does it mean? It means that
I'm going to be given this brief instead
of some other guy. Cool. No big deal.
You know what? Why don't you give the
brief? I'm fine with that. Yeah. So yeah,
respect,
humility and
never above you, never below
you, always beside you.
It's a good little thing
to think about there again.
Did you ever have the situations where
you're throwing darts at the guys back at
the bar, you know, for your
hazing situation? No. No.
Sure. Yeah, we did some pretty,
we did some pretty rough hazing though.
Uh, for sure. You know, lots, lots of, uh,
yeah, it was, it was
not fun. It wasn't fun.
It wasn't fun and it was part
of the ritual back in the day.
It's not as much as any as it is, not
as much as that anymore, but you know,
guess what, guys are fighting a
war now. Yeah. So I'm not like, oh,
they'll guys don't have it as
hard. Guess what the, when I got,
when I was in the team, so
when I first got to the teams,
it was like, oh, cool. Oh,
you're in the teams. Yeah,
you're going to get hazed. Ooh.
Guess what these guys are, can get
nowadays they're going to get shot at,
they're going to get
hit with idds. So, uh,
not that big of a deal.
It's just a little bit of a culture
change and that's the way it is.
Next question. Dichotomy of
leadership has some great principles.
What is it appropriate
philosophy concerning time
to train versus manage out a
direct report when they have
been in the role for over eight.
Yeah.
This changes from industry to industry
to spend depending on the situation that
you're in and sometimes you don't have,
you have a really tight timeline to get
people up to speed and if they don't get
up to speed,
you've got to get rid of him on.
Otherwise it's going to cost the team
or it's going to cost the company money.
So how long are you going to give them?
You're going to give them as much time
as you think you can give them before
they started to tracking from the team.
You're also gonna make sure that you're
not investing so much time in one person
to try and get them up to speed,
that you're ignoring everyone else and
now it's having a negative impact on the
team. So you just got to
look at the timing. Again,
I worked with construction companies where
if they don't get a job done on time,
it'll cost them $60,000 a day.
They don't play around like they need
someone that's going to be able to get the
job done.
You'll get some sales organization that's
commission only and there's somebody
that's taken a while to get up to speed.
They don't really care.
It's not costing the company anything.
So you've got to figure out in your
industry how much time that looks like and
then you got to set the
expectations clearly. And once
you've done that, you say,
okay, listen bud, I've been working
with for this amount of time.
Here's where I want you to be at
this date. If you don't get there,
we're going to move you out. Math, it's
the way it is pretty straight forward.
Okay.
Next question.
I have to coexist at times with an
individual who knows I'm ex army.
He purposely makes pro Taliban quips to
Piss me off as I'm in a position I can't
do much about it.
His intent to anger works,
but I don't show it.
What's some advice? Yeah, I
mean this guy's just a, just,
just completely ignore them, you
know? And I actually, you know, hey,
that's funny man. Cool. Yeah.
He's obviously trying to get under your
skin and just don't let them get under
your skin. That's just
all there is to it. Um,
this person is a worthless
and just ignore him. I mean,
you could go to the extreme of taking,
like in Mark's mission where mark
actually gets in on the joke,
you know? And if you want it, you
know, but then you might be crossing.
I again,
I don't know the specifics
of the situation because
there's times where that's
not like, I wouldn't do that
in certain situations. I got
like, no, I'll ignore you,
but I'm not going to play along with
this joke the way you're saying it,
but there's times where I'd be
like, Oh yeah, guess what? You know,
I might play along with a joke just to
diffuse it again. If this might be a,
this might be a guy that doesn't deserve
that, but, uh, yeah, ignore it, man. Go.
Don't even worry about this
idiot. That's, that's my advice.
Yeah, that ignore thing. You do that
super good where it's literally like,
he, you feel like you
don't, you got no feedback.
From my little joke,
like if I make a joke to you or something
and it's almost like did he not hear
my joke cause he just sort of
moved on, you know, kind of thing.
And it's really compelling me to like
not tell that joke anymore, you know,
kind of thing. And I'm assuming
it works real good actually.
Um, and he actually did have an
example, like the guy would say, hey,
you're eating the Taliban with this,
with the check this week.
Like I don't know if the check is
junk or this week's check. Anyway.
So it seems like he's trying to be funny.
You know,
like now he's not trying to be a dick
to the guy alone when he says he's
purposely trying to piss them off.
And so for me,
if you're purposely trying to piss me off,
me getting pissed off as you running,
that's the pay. I'm not going to
let that happen. We're going to win.
How am I going to win by
not getting pissed off?
And you're a little and your ignore tactic
that you do in real life, by the way.
And I'm not saying like the ignore where
you're like, like a little kid again,
doors like a little chaotic, just ignore
them and they like turn their back.
Now it's like, oh yeah, you
know, just like, yeah, just
like meaningless. Like your,
your little quips literally
mean nothing to me whatsoever.
So whatever. Yeah, and that's a skill too,
which apparently you've honed over the
years because it is and you gotta you
can't oversell it. You can't
oversell ignoring somebody
otherwise you're like, ah,
I got the payoff.
So you can't oversell it.
And underselling ignoring means like
you're not really ignoring I guess.
But if you can nail it,
if you can nail it like literally your
joke or your comments or whatever are
falling on deaf ears, you know, and
they don't like affect me at all.
If you can nail that.
Yeah,
I would say that that would compel a
normal person or this kind of person,
whatever, to stop it. Where I think that
works with everybody. Having little kids.
Once again, you don't make a spectacle out
of yourself. It's going to let it roll.
Like you're not making a spectacle
of like I'm ignoring you don't make a
spectacle of like shut up,
you just play it in the metal
and you just go because,
because there's things in
life that don't matter.
I'm not saying
that you, that there, that there's,
that there's things that you don't react
to because there certainly are. Yeah.
And I'm not saying that you want to
be this neutral person through for all
things,
but there's things that just don't matter.
There's things that just, they just
don't matter. And this is one of them.
This guy doesn't matter what is,
who is this guy? It doesn't matter.
So don't put any effort into
them. Just stay neutral. Oh,
give him a smile and a nod and
keep doing what you're doing.
Another tip too for this, don't tell
other people like, oh that pissing me off.
And then you forgot about the ever,
never tell anyone when
something pisses you off. Never.
You know that way.
Cause if you do and then you're,
you're nailing the ignore tactic,
you're nailing delivery perfectly.
Someone else. And then you told, you
told your friend or whatever, like, Hey,
that guy knows that all,
he's just ignoring me by
that really pisses them off,
you know, so they'll
just keep doing it. And,
and here's the thing too about
playing the game. Like come or,
or going along with the joke like ha yeah,
that's funny.
You just base,
you kind of involve yourself in the game.
He's not getting the pay off necessarily,
but he'll just change this tactic because
you're still in the game where you
want to, you want to get
out of the game. That's why,
that's why in that particular
situation, um, you know,
mark and Mark's mission was trying
to befriend. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's a different situation.
He's not just trying to diffuse or he's
trying to actually befriend him and so
then he needed to make a connection.
That's the clear difference.
If this guy was like a coworker or a boss
or a subordinate and trying to build a
relationship with, then I might take
a little step, you know? And again,
am I going to joke about
somebody being pro Taliban?
I'm not probably joking
about the Taliban very much.
No. Yeah. Cool. Next question.
Is it better to remain single if you
have a dangerous or demanding career in
order to protect your family from
unintended negative consequences or find a
partner willing to embrace the
risk and raise were kids together?
Hey Man,
uh,
it's hard to live the life and it's a
lot harder on your family than it is on
you because you'll be over getting after
it and your family will be at home not
knowing what's going on with
you. So it's hard. But I mean,
obviously having kids and raising
a little warrior kids with a,
with a partner that's in the game is,
is awesome.
It's hard to find someone
to get married to.
That's that good to go in the game,
especially if they're real young.
So I got real lucky. I married a
girl that kind of got it. We'll say.
And,
and I said this when I was
on Ben Shapiro's show that
the quality that she had
and still has,
that I think is,
is the most important is,
um, emotional independence. And I
don't even know if that's a thing.
I don't know if I just made that up.
But that's the trying to describe that.
You know,
my wife doesn't need the,
the hey honey from me.
She doesn't need to like a hey,
how's everything going? She doesn't
need that from me. She's fine.
She's emotionally independent and,
and of course she's independent in the
way that she can take care of whatever
the kids and the puke and kids and the
kids diapers and the kids with and the
broken water heater and
the flat tire on the car.
You can handle all that stuff too.
When I was gone a lot.
But most important is she could,
she didn't need the constant like
emotional recharge from me cause she's a
independent,
stable human being of her own.
So I think that's the kind of
thing you've got to look for. Now,
unfortunately a lot of times dudes
are attracted to the person that's
emotionally dependent on them because
it makes them a little ego boost and it
makes them feel good. Like, oh she
needs me around. And it's like,
that's so,
so you've gotta watch out for that.
You've got to find someone that kind
of has their own thing going on,
which also has to be balanced because
if you find a female that is too has too
much independence, then guess what? She
ain't gonna be around when you go home,
you gotta find somebody else. So you've
got to find that balance as well. Uh,
but if you can find that right person,
don't rush into it.
Take your time and, and, and
she's in the game then. Yeah,
man. Get after it. I got to say.
That's a good question. Yeah, it is.
And you know, a lot of times guys, guys,
and here's another,
like this is just an,
it's an answer that's not really an
answer. And yet it's fully an answer. Hey,
I'm married and I'm thinking
about going the seal teams.
So what will this do to my
marriage? It's like, oh,
there's a 50% chance your marriage,
he's going to get destroyed because
you're going to be gone all the time.
Your wife is going to
be jealous of the teams.
She's going to be jealous of the travel.
She's going to be pissed
that you're not home.
that when you get home,
you're going to the bar with your boys
instead of going to the recital for the
daughter. Like that's,
that's a reality. So yeah,
I can't recommend it.
At the same time,
if you're squared away and you have a good
relationship, yeah, that'll be awesome.
That'll be awesome. But it's, it's
a really hard, like when guys,
when I meet a guy that's 19 years old, 20
years old, and he says, yeah, he know him.
I'm going to buds and I'm getting married
this summer before I go straight up.
That's a bad idea. That's a
bad idea. Don't do that. If
you're in that situation,
don't do that because if you are,
if you have a great relationship
with that person, you say, look,
I'm going to go through buds.
I'm going to be focused on that.
It's going to take me some time.
I'm going to show up at a team.
I'm going to go on deployment.
I'm going to come home.
It's going to take about three
years for all this to happen.
When we get done with,
when I get done with all that,
we'll get married because we are so strong
and so tight that we can get through
three years without, you
know, being married. We cool.
Let's see what kind of
response you get from that
because it's its non committal, right?
Cause it's showing, uh, the female, Hey,
I'm noncommittal when actually
you're saying, listen,
it's not that I'm noncommittal. I don't
even know what I holds in the future.
I don't know what the future holds for me.
It's going to be crazy.
I don't know what's going to happen.
I don't want to drag you
through a bunch of crap.
Let's just pause on moving forward with
the marriage part and once we get done
with that, you know,
gimme gimme two years.
Give me three years and then you can
see if you still want to be around you,
you think you want to be around
right now you haven't had it.
You haven't had a dude that's going on
deployment for seven months after he gets
done with a one year workup
where I was gone in 12 months,
I was gone nine months. That's
a whole nother thing. You,
you may not want to be in that
situation, you know, ma'am.
So if you're in that situation,
yeah,
don't get married and don't do
people pull it off sometimes. Yeah.
Flint and Cochran got
married I think before buds.
And so that's, that's a one guy. But,
but it's a rare occasion and most of
the time it doesn't work out as well as
Flint. It worked out for Flint.
Why did it work out for fluid?
One of the reasons he married a girl that
is emotionally independent and can do
her own thing and wasn't waiting
on, you know, that that debt,
emotional boost,
you know?
So there you go.
I sent the SA and here's the final answer.
It's like,
you know what the right answer is.
You actually know it.
So many questions you actually know the
answer to when you want reinforcement of
them and,
but,
but the only person that can answer these
questions is you the person you got to
listen to what I'm saying? Sure. Yeah.
But you got to look at your
future spouse and be like,
or po potential spouse.
You're the one that knows.
Now what's hard is guys,
especially guys,
they go head over heels for
females. Yeah, they go crazy.
They go nuts. They don't even
see straight. Yeah you can't.
I had guys in seal platoons where
I was like, listen, hey bro,
this girl that you're involved with
right now is going to ruin your life.
I want to tell you that.
Let me tell you what she's done so far.
You're not married yet.
I know you want to get married in two
weeks so far she stole your credit card.
She's called the command four times to
request to talk to the master chief about
your orders. This girl's a
nightmare. Please do not marry
her and guys are like,
Bro, you don't understand
and that's the way guys do.
And how do I know that?
Cause I was the same idiot when
when you're 15 years old, oh my God.
It's the only, no. It's like, no,
that's not the only girl. It's not.
There's more. So just calm
down if you can. If you,
if the marriage is meant to be,
let it be, but let it be in a year.
Let it happen in here.
Don't be getting married in three months.
Don't be getting married in two months.
Don't, don't get married in six months.
Get married in a year. Get married
in a year and a half. Do me a favor.
Do yourself a favor to us.
Do us all a favor.
There you go. Sounds like sound
advice. Thank you. Next question.
Could you talk about how you read a book
to get so much out of it that you do?
Yeah. Um, here's what I do. When
I read a book, I read the book.
As I'm reading the book, I highlight
the important parts of the book.
Then I go back through and reread
what I highlight and pull out the pre,
the, the Creme de la creme of the
information, another small thick.
If you're reading a book where there's
lots of characters right down the
characters and kind of like give them
a description so you can refer back to
them when they show back up again.
Cause sometimes I'll lose track of
characters if it's a complex book and you
just don't, you just don't know. Um,
so that's what I do. I read slowly.
I actually, it's horrible. I
wish I read faster. I read it.
The speed that I talk just about,
I'd read a little bit faster,
but it's just about the speed that
I talk and I read every single word.
And when I will say this, when I do read
a book slowly and like I do read it,
I remember a lot from the book,
which is cool,
but read it slowly, highlight it,
take notes. There you go. Hmm.
Makes Sense. Next question.
What was plying beat?
If you rang the bell, there
was no, I wasn't going to ring.
Your Bell wasn't going to happen.
It's seriously wasn't going to happen.
And but well here's what
could have happened. Injury.
You can get injured in buds and some
injuries are more permit preventative,
like Shin splints.
If you trained properly beforehand,
you probably won't get Shin splints. But
if you're doing a rock portage and you,
there's big waves and you're bringing
a boat, a Zodiac boat or uh, uh, IBS,
boat up the rocks in big waves,
you can just get your knee broke.
Like it can happen. So then what would
have happened if I would've gotten,
I would've gone to the
fleet, healed up, come back.
So what I would have done it again.
You got to try again. It's a,
that's one of the scariest things about
buds from a guy that like the guys that
I know that we're like, yeah, we're never
gonna quit, but they, there's a possible,
you're going to get injured. Can you
get real? They call it rolled, right?
You can get rolled back, eat.
Like even if you get sick, right?
Like a doctor can be like, hey, you
can't continue. Yep. That can happen.
That can happen. That happens.
The guys in hell week,
they'll get pneumonia and they're
just, they can't, like, they're,
they're not quitting.
But they're coughing up blood,
they're speeding blood out of their mouth
and you're like, and the doctor's like,
Hey, are you okay? I'm fine.
And so they just have to, they
just have to get rolled back. Yeah.
It happens. There's very few people
that don't get rolled back. Oh yeah.
It's a pretty small number that don't
get rolled back at all. Really? Yeah.
Like for medical, medical failure. If you
fail something, you can get more about.
If you fail a run,
I forget why.
I don't know what it is right now when I
went through, if you failed to run, okay,
you gotta write up. If you felt another
run, you've got rolled back. See,
good to do the whole thing again. Got
To do the whole thing, not just the run.
You got to do everything
again. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The
whole thing was a nightmare.
So I failed.
I'll run
a swim
a obstacle course like,
and then you just freaked out.
I was so paranoid. I think you
could actually, when I went through,
you could fail one per phase. So there was
three phases. First Phase, second phase,
third phase. You could fail like one
of each thing per phase, which is,
which sounds really lenient,
but Dang you're doing because
you're doing a timed run every week,
a timed run every week,
and then you're doing a million.
They just call them a conditioning runs,
which is the most understated
name for run ever,
because what they really were is just
the most grueling as fast as you could go
through the soft sand runs
for how long for no, no,
no dude, no, and not only that, you ran,
you ran to breakfast and back
then Randall, lunch and back,
we rented dinner and back in each
one of those runs was one mile,
so there's six miles before you ran
anywhere before you conditioning,
you run and your time drawn.
You're doing a six mile run every day.
Just that's awesome.
That is not a sprint.
Sometimes you have to run fast. Sometimes
you run slow, but it's just like a sh.
A lot of times it's just a little, you
know, typical military shuffle. Yeah.
So yeah, when I was, no man.
Next question.
What actual strategy should do you get
to white belt employed during a role
other than relaxed tap early,
tap off and like touch her.
All those are other key points.
But the other thing is I would say try
and do moves that you've actually learned
instead of instead of doing
something that you, that you, uh,
just like your spazzing out trying to
do some random thing and actually do
something that you know,
and if you get in a situation
that you don't know what to do,
remember the situation you were in
such, you can ask an instructor, hey,
here's where I was. I didn't know what
Duke, can you please help me? Simple.
Pretty straight forward.
The question,
if a coworker were attempting to bully,
intimidate,
or make you generally miserable,
do you go with it?
Would you make a mention of your
Jujitsu knowledge or keep it a surprise?
I like that question. Oh yeah,
I would keep it. Um, I'm,
I keep everything a surprise.
Right?
I just keep everything.
I'm surprised because I'm not here like,
you know, are they are digital, you better
back off, you know, like what is that?
And instead you're just like,
hey man, all good. Hmm. You know,
and then let that guy find out for
himself that, you know the hardwood. Yeah.
Either the hard way or
someone will be like, hey man,
you know that guy that you keep messing
with? Like I train Jujitsu every day.
He's going to choke you out and put you
to sleep and then guess what he's gonna
do. He's gonna get mouthy.
Cause he's already been,
he's already been testing you and he's
like, oh, he's kind of a wimp. So yeah,
I mean there's no, like, is there even a
cool way you can say I trained Jujitsu?
No, because even if you pull it off
externally, like internally, you're like,
you know who said it?
John Claude van Damme.
Heuler Gracie Coiler Gracie was surfing.
Yeah.
And I think kid Pellagra told me this
story, but it might've been Hawaii that,
that told me this, he was surfing
and somebody wanted to, you know,
give them some beef getting up. And
you wanted somebody wanting to do like,
you know, hey, what are you doing out here
in type thing? And he was like, you know,
he did what I would do with like, you
know, he just kept surfing kind of,
and then the person started talking more
and then he started running his mouth
and then heuler said something like,
Hey,
you like to surf?
I like to fight. If you want
to fight, we can do that.
And uh, I thought that was a
pretty cool way of saying it.
He told that story I think of,
unless he told another time to you at
Brian's sergeants promotion to black belt.
I think kids really grew
through too. I forget, but yes,
he told me he told that
story to the group.
He told it to me and I thought that I
was there. Right. Yeah, he was. Yeah.
I thought there was like kind
of more cooler than that.
Said it cooler than that.
He said it some way that was like,
yeah, listen, you like to fight.
You like to surf for your life.
I find that you surf for a living.
I fight for a living. It was
something even more than what I said,
but it was good.
Yeah,
we can find the kind of concern for it
was the kind of thing where you're like,
if you were that guy,
you think you know, yeah,
maybe I'll not do this
whole thing right now.
I remember thinking the same thing as you,
like think that was a really
dope way to say it. You know?
Plus like you know that that guy,
obviously he didn't know who that was.
I'm assuming it,
which would be kind of crazy if he did
it or if he did know who he was, but,
and then what if hypothetically
later he found out who that was.
Occasionally I've had people say things
like, uh, like they kind of know who said,
they'll say like, oh, you know, let's
go. You got something like that. Yeah.
And it's like, yeah, man, cool. I, that's
always my answer. Oh, awesome. Yeah. Cool.
Do you want to go now? And then they're
always like, [inaudible]. Just kidding.
Cool. All right, next question.
What do you typically wear when you
meet the bosses of companies? And why?
Oh Amen.
If you're working with echelon front,
then pretty much what we all,
where's the ETF Polo?
The echelon front, a polo shirt.
And you know, we, we, we called the,
what we were business tactical,
just polo shirt and a pair of pants.
And why the question is why?
Well that's just because it's a,
to me it's the same kind of
thing I've been talking about.
Just sort of a normal
thing to wear. Right. Um,
don't really travel as much as
I travel as little as possible.
I came with a full suit and yeah.
So just comfort and functionality.
Yeah, there's the answer. Yeah.
And of course he won't show up
in your shorts. Yeah, no, no.
We're professional in rash guard.
Yeah.
He used to wear a suit, right?
Like back in the, yeah, I mean,
and I still wear will wear a
suit sometimes, but usually
not, man. Usually not.
You know, even, um, usually people,
people know who we are now and
so if we're going to show up,
they realize what they're getting,
which is like, hey these guys are,
these guys are going to come in and
talk to us and they didn't know what the
deal is.
Yeah there's all the footage of us on,
on the videos and stuff were
wearing kind of the eff uniform.
So business tactical, get
some. All right, next question.
And I guess there is a, there is a uh,
a small bit of like, hey we're not,
we're not standard business
people. You know what I mean? Yeah,
that makes sense.
Okay.
Like you're in a room with people with
a bunch of suits on and they're like,
oh who's presenting?
Oh it's that guy over there cause
he's wearing something different.
Okay we get it.
You know what I mean?
We're just a little identifier
echelon front on the shirt.
All good. Good. How do you grill better,
faster, stronger with your romantic
partner over time without being a brute?
I just,
I don't even,
I just kind of had to put this
question in here cause it was,
I don't really understand.
I mean,
just because you're bigger and faster and
stronger, it doesn't mean Europe boot.
Right. What, what does that,
how do you overcome that and
be nice to your, you know,
your girlfriend or your wife, um,
what's the, your romantic partner?
Like what does that mean though?
Like if you're working out with your
romantic partner or like you're getting
bigger and faster and stronger
and therefore you start
treating your girlfriend
like cracked. I'm like
no, it's like no dude.
Actually you'll probably be nicer because
you're bigger, faster and stronger.
So it's kind of a non question I guess.
But I just thought it was
funny is cause you fake.
You think, Hey, I'm in it,
I'm going to do squats today.
Then I'm just going to [inaudible]
being a Brit,
the being a brute,
that part I can see, I could see
that, you know, cause you know,
like let's say like you gained
20 pounds, 30 pounds. It's just,
and it's like all muscle. You're super
strong now. You know. I don't know.
And you know, you come home, you're just
more of a, like the stuff that you do,
you know your fact Kimmy, you know,
like you're just way more brutish.
You are. Yes. So Do, so
I dunno. Vacuum a harder,
oh you gotta vacuum with more finesse.
You gotta focus on the finesse part of it.
Otherwise you're going to be all big,
fast and strong. That the, and I um,
I think I understand the question,
but here's a,
here's a tip that I haven't been
married forever but significantly long.
Here's what I found out. Like a lot of
stuff, like as a guy you think like,
Hey, I'm not really going to do that
because that's not important. You know,
like you have a set of things that you
think are important and they're based on
certain ways of thinking and the girl's
going to have things she thinks is
important. And in my
experience, which I to,
from what I understand is very common
that the things that some girls think are
important,
they can't really put their finger on it
or why they feel important or whatever.
But they just do, you know? And the guy
will be like, hey, that's an unimportant.
You can't even explain why it's important.
Therefore I win the whole importance,
significance argument, right?
So at the end of the day,
they're not going to do these
things. Just little things, you know,
show me that you care.
Like these sensitive things,
things that go against being faster,
stronger,
more brutish.
But if you can keep in mind
that little little things,
even if you don't think
they're significant,
actually do make your
romantic partner happy.
And if you can consist consistently
maintain that regardless of how big,
fast or strong you get that oil,
she's going to embrace your big bigness,
fastness and strongness.
Take her from me. I know.
Cool. Next question.
In cooperation and negotiation,
is there a tell to know
when you're breaking your
personal code and compromising
too much?
Is,
is it a gut check or is it gut check
or logical? This is a weird one.
There's a kind of a confusing question,
so I'll just kind of kind of a answer
it to the best of my ability. Well,
the biggest thing I notice when I'm,
when I'm interacting with other people,
the biggest thing that I pay
attention to is am I paying it to him?
Do I care about this particular
thing because of me or because
of it's going to help the team. Yeah.
And if you can get through that, if you,
if you really just say to yourself,
Hey,
am I doing this because I'm
going to help the team or my,
am I doing this because it's about me?
If you pay attention to those things,
and I'm not saying that every time
that you say, hey, you know what,
I need to take care of me a little bit
because you have to remember that you
have your strategic goals too.
Right?
But most of the time the success of
the team is going to help you strategic
goals now. So for me, I'm,
my constant thing is, hey,
why am I, why? Why does this
concern me? Does it concern me?
It's basically does this
concern because my ego or not,
and if it doesn't concern
me because of my ego,
that it concerns me because it's
not going to benefit the team.
So let's help the team.
So that's, that's what I,
that's what I look at the most when
I'm negotiating, when I'm cooperating,
you know, if, if, if you and I
were negotiating a deal, right?
And I was going to buy a
car from you and I was like,
you know,
you want to sell it for me to for 10
grand and I want to get it for nine,
how much of it? And you're like,
okay, you know what, Jocko, I,
I got it on the lot for for 8,800 can
you give me $400 over the what I paid for
it and give me 9,200 or
whatever. And I'm like, no,
I'll only, how much of that is
me? Just, it was just my ego.
I just want to win the ego fight against
you. And how much of it is me? Like, Hey,
that's actually a pretty good deal. Yeah.
And, and why not take care of this guy?
Because I don't know. I don't
really know you, but hey man,
maybe we'll buy something else in
the future. Maybe I'll, you'll have,
you know what I mean? So am I trying,
is it my ego or is it just a bad deal?
If you're like, hey, nope, it's 11,000
and I'm like, okay, you know what?
I'm not going to pay that.
So it's not, it's not my ego.
That's just not a good deal at 10 grand.
It's not a great deal at 9,200 it's
a pretty damn good deal for me.
And it's,
you're going to make some money and I'm
happy that you're going to make some
money. Cool. You know what? Let's
shake hands. Let's make a deal.
There's times where this is the,
so this is the point.
There's times where it
my ego, I'll be like, no,
I don't care. I don't care if
you're only going to make 200 bucks,
that's that's your problem.
You should have paid so much.
When in my heart I know like,
Hey, that's actually a good deal.
I'm getting a really good deal,
but my ego is not letting me have closed
close it. Um, that can be a death.
That can be a problem.
So when I'm negotiating with
someone and it's not a good deal,
they're not going to get me
to do what they want me to do.
It's just not going to happen. If it's
a fair deal, hey, we'll make it work.
It was not a fair deal.
It's going to be problematic.
You don't want to present me with unfair
deals because I will not be accepting
them. Also. Does it seem
like it's more of a question,
I guess you kind of got
to like be to yourself
like consciously too,
right? Because when you,
cause you give it like how you said
you got to ask yourself, is this,
is this good for me and my ego
or is this good for the team?
Like as far as me not
compromising my, uh, you know,
not compromising or my personal code or
whatever and there's values that I will
not compromise. There's values that
I will not compromise. It would,
I would think that that'd be for
a very specific reason. You know,
you know how like some people there'll
be like, I'm just not like that,
but they don't really know why.
Like, Hey, well I don't know.
Maybe cause my dad told me that one time
when we were fishing or whatever it,
so there's a difference. This is what
I'm saying. So, but here's the thing,
and I say this because this is what I'll
do. Sometimes I'll be like, hey, you know,
this is more important because of,
you know,
I don't know my hell oh you'll
rationalize. Yeah. You know,
and yeah, essentially like
twist the truth to myself too.
To kind of explain to myself
again how important this is,
you know, for the team, you know, one
of those things, if that's important.
There's other ways to do that. To
your point, that's what I'm saying,
when I'm thinking about
decisions, I'm asking myself, Hey,
is this my ego or is this or am I
doing the right thing for the road?
For the team. Yeah. Cause there's, that's
what you should be checking on, right.
If you're doing it for yourself,
most 99% of the time,
if you're doing something for
yourself that hurts the team,
the longterm is not going to
be beneficial to you. Okay.
The longterm is not going to
be beneficial to you. Yeah,
because you're doing something
for yourself. Everybody sees that.
You don't think they see
it, but they see it. Yeah.
So you try and do things that are going
to benefit the team and sometimes I'm
99% of the time when you do
something that benefits team,
you're going to benefit from it as well.
But you have to see the long game because
sometimes the short game it's like,
oh no, if I do this for the team, that
means I'm going to miss this this weekend.
And that sucks. Well, guess
what? In the long term,
when you work this weekend and cover for
the other guys that couldn't make it in
for whatever reason,
you're going to have a better relationship
with them and they're going to come
for free next time. It's like, it's
longterm, it's gonna be good. Yeah.
But you're worried about you and that's,
that's problem playing the long game
again, always got to play that long name.
Next question. Best Way to get
your teeth. Get you team in.
Okay. Best Way to get your team to buy in
to your vision. Let it be their vision.
I'll let me let the vision come from them.
Right?
And the more the vision comes from them,
the more the plan comes from them,
the more they buy into it,
the more you force the vision and
forced the plan down their throat,
the less buy in that you're
going to get from it. Now you,
if you're super persuasive, you can do
a better job of coming up with a vision.
But why do that? Why not
say, hey guys, you know what?
We're going to put together the
direction that this team is going.
Give me some feedback. Give me
some bullet points. Hit me now.
They all come back with bullet points you
assembled together and it's like, Hey,
this is what we're going to go in.
Boom. Everyone's on board. That easy.
Our plan. Yeah, so much easier with our
plan. And you if you're scared of that.
And I think if all, if I give the team
the opportunity to come up with a plan,
they're going to come up
with a plan that sucks. Well,
how well did you train them?
If they come up with a plan that socks,
you haven't trained them very well. Most
of the time. If you train them decently,
they're gonna come up with a plan that's
close enough to the a decent plan that
they can go and execute it. You
weaken all, execute it together.
That can be part of the vision.
Let's go,
Hey Jocko,
what would be better verbal communication
with concept of prioritize and
execute?
When talking to my wife,
she oftentimes feels overwhelmed with
how many decisions she has to make.
She hates when I use the words
of prioritize and execute.
Well, the root problem there
isn't that she hates the, the,
the words prioritize and execute.
The problem is, is that you're,
you're telling her what
to do. That's, you know,
instead of being like, hey, you know,
hey, if you just prioritize and execute,
there's,
if there's a at least an eight f at
least a 50% chance that she doesn't even
want to hear your suggestion. She's
just telling you, cause it's vet,
she's venting to you. So
for you to be like, man,
those are a lot of decisions to make.
That's hard. If you were to say to her,
how do you,
how do you handle this?
Cause I know you're doing this everyday
girl, I'm impressed. How do you do that?
And then she says, well, you know,
it's hard, but here's what I do.
So if it was just a matter of
renaming it, it's like, hey,
we'll call it, hey, you know what you
need to do is great and go, or what you,
what you need to do is rank and role.
What do you need to do is triage and
check off what you need to do or,
or designate and do.
That's what, you know,
there's a bunch of different
ways you could phrase it,
but that's not what's making
her responded in a negative way.
She's responding in a negative
way cause you're saying, hey,
here's all you need to do is
prioritize and execute this. Know
what she needs is some sympathy,
some listening,
allowing to vent, and
then you can say, hey,
you know,
if you've done that properly you can say,
well you know I did read that book and
they kind of say when there's a bunch of
crazy things going on
like you've got going on,
they say to do the same
thing that I see you do,
which is you pick the most important
one and then you kind of focus on that.
That's pretty cool. Can you do that?
I'm pretty well by the way you do that.
Well you do that really well.
So just take a little different approach,
man. Yeah. It's not just the words.
The words are not putting,
I hate to break the news to your brother
words not pissing her off. You are.
Listen to her. It seems you ever notice
some people, they'd come you a problem.
They don't want a solution. Oh
yeah. That happens all the time.
They just want you to sit there and listen
to them. My wife does that for sure.
For sure. You know, hey, there's this
problem. Oh, why don't you do this?
It's not that easy. Okay. Fuck you.
Just tell me more about the problem
and I'll sit over here and listen.
Don't say that by the
way, you got to do that.
That part. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
It's almost like when he's like,
it seems like they,
yeah. That they don't mind so much of
the suffering of the problem. Suffering.
I'm overusing that word. I know, but
yeah, they don't mind the suffering.
They just want to, they don't want to
suffer alone. So it feel like, Oh yeah,
I'm having like these issues of
whatever first is like, hey, come see,
suffer with me. Sympathize,
empathize, or whatever.
We can suffer together that that's why
I'm coming to you in the first place so I
can get closer to you. Whatever, whatever.
I don't know that I'm
totally reflect and diminish.
Do remember when I talked about that?
Yes. Such a good tactic in this situation.
Reflect the emotions back to them.
Yeah, but diminish them a little bit.
So if they're all freaking
mad about something, you go,
oh, I can't believe that.
But you don't be as mad as them, but
you don't be, hey, calm down. You don't,
you don't say, Hey, here's
just prioritize next cute,
oh it's a rough one actually,
to be honest.
Like I felt that before where I'd come
to my brother's typically the one like
I've come to him with like a problem.
And here's the thing,
I didn't want like sympathy or empathy
primarily, but I wanted a little bit,
you know, so you can't just roll suit
there with your apple or whatever,
all cash and went through, what are
you going to do is put this, you know,
like Kinda like you're so dumb.
You get this feeling.
I'm not saying you want to know why your
brother or you or whoever can look at
that problem and like come up with
a solutions cause they're detached,
they're be facto detached
from the problem.
And so when you're all wrapped up
in the problem, you're like, hey,
I don't know what to do cause I got this,
this and this. And your brother's like,
well just do that and you're like,
you get mad.
He's able to see what to do
because he's on the outside. Yeah.
So if you can learn to, to
detach yourself, you won't
have to rely on getting,
getting other people to help you.
If you can't detach and you're all wrapped
up in the emotions of the situation,
you're gonna, you're gonna have to go with
someone to help. And then when you do,
don't get mad at them when they
just tell you the solution.
But when you reverse the roles and you
take ownership of trying to provide
solutions,
you've got to realize that it's your
fault that your solution isn't being
welcomed here.
And that's kind of the point where like
I'm trying to gain an understanding,
you know,
cause easy when your detections first
thing is like why are you complaining
about like, cause this is how you
feel on the front of your mind.
You're like why are you
complaining about this?
Why don't you just solve that problem
and never complained about it ever again.
You know, that's the feeling the other
person had that detached person, the hut,
you know, in this case,
the husband and whatever.
So what I did was I imagine my situation
that I'm on the other side where kind
of like, I know what it feels like
to kind of want some sympathy.
I don't want sympathy and that's
it, you know? But of course,
but I want some of it. So
imagine that feeling then. Well,
I imagine that feeling that I got from
my brother at times when I come to him
with a problem that's
bothering me or whatever,
and the part and the fact that it's
bothering me means nothing. All my hands.
So the fact that the way he presents a
solution with no empathy and almost says,
actually it feels like
it says you're so dumb,
like you're dumb. You know, like why
are you wrapped up about this thing?
You're dumb kind of thing. So
from a leadership perspective,
from his perspective,
he should recognize that what he needs
to do is a massager ego feel good about
it and be like, Oh man, that's a
hell of a problem to have. You know,
one thing I could maybe you could do,
I don't know if you'd be up,
I don't know if I could do it,
but you could probably do because you're
a little bit better at this kind of
thing. You just cut off just
doing that little dude. Yeah,
that's a good tactic right there.
When you say like what, what you,
what you kind of do kind of like,
you're like one of these individuals,
one of the rare people who knows how to
deal with it and it's like empowering.
Nothing that you do that I can't
really do as see you do it though,
is you prioritize an accident.
I just get all scatterbrained,
so focus on all kinds of different things
at the same time and that's a problem.
There you go. Get some
next question. My worry.
Your kids want to know is where
your kid number three in the works.
Yes. Warrior kid three is in
the works. I am on chapter 10.
Unfortunately, I've been on
chapter 10 for a couple of days,
not because it's taken me a long time
to write chapter 10 but I didn't write
yesterday or the day before because
we were doing multiple podcasts,
which is a bummer. But uh, be back on
the path today. As a matter of fact,
well, technically you're on the path.
Your path is just super white. You know,
you had to switch lanes for a little bit.
You don't miss it, you miss the exit,
but you know, boom, you're back on
in that lane in on the same path.
And we're looking at, we're looking at
spring publication for that. Once again,
get it out there.
I'm really having fun writing this book.
That's the characters develop more
complex, complex, or some complexities.
There's some situations that mark
hasn't really had to deal with yet.
The primary being Danny Reinhardt.
So brace yourself for the impact of Danny
Reinhart. Praise yourself. All right,
next question.
Your lifestyle is intense and intentional.
How do I even get started
living like that? Let's just
break this down real easy.
Okay. Um, uh, number one, if you want
to live like more focused in your life,
choose to decide that you're going
to actually live like that. Do that.
Write down whatever it is you want to do.
And then before you go to bed at night,
write down some things
that you can do tomorrow.
They're going to help you move towards
the goals that you have and then set your
alarm clock for early in the morning,
wake up and do the things you wrote down.
Stay on that path. That's it. Yeah.
And do you think that you've just sort
of grown accustomed to just dealing with
it? That was, you know, the more
you do it. Yeah, absolutely.
So that's Kinda the hard part,
right? To get off the ground.
She was saying to break the gravitational
pull of, of laziness and apathy.
Yes. Yeah. And of course that,
but I feel like that in
this kind of situation, like
when you live, how intently
intense. Sure. But you kind
of always been intense.
But that intentional situation cause
it's pretty easy if you know a goal,
it's pretty,
I won't say easy,
but it's simple like to reach that
goal is really clear. You know,
like you're going to have to fight
through obstacles, all this other stuff.
But if you don't really have
an intentional like goal,
it's hard to just kind of float there
and be like, I need to be, I dunno,
vaguely successful.
It's like it's,
it makes the whole deal harder and it's
a lot of times like a normal person
would, they don't have specific goals
for every aspect of their life. You know,
they'll have one in maybe
with their career or something
like that or fitness or
something like that. But everything
else is just sort of, hey,
I'm living day by day doing the best
I can kind of thing. But if you can,
whether it be write it down and whatever,
if you can have it in your
brain consciously that,
or remember essentially like what these
goals are, it makes it a lot more clear.
And then the more you kind
of follow those goals,
the more it becomes like a
habit. Like you, it's what I
think. Check. Next question.
How do the finest civilian leaders differ
from the finest military leaders or in
other words,
what character traits do military leaders
to develop that are more difficult,
are rare for, uh, for
civilian leaders to develop.
They're really,
the leadership is leadership and the
good civilian leaders have the same good
qualities that the good military
leaders have. And vice versa.
And Lafe Lafe was talking about this
the other day that, you know, he,
he tells people like, Hey man, I wish
you were in the military, was your,
you would have been good. You know, you
would have been a good infantry officer.
You'd have a good seal platoon leader.
That would have been cool if you were in
the teams because you're a good leader
in the civilian sector.
You're a good leader in the,
you'd be a good leader in the military.
So there's no,
and now there are strengths and
weaknesses for leaders in both of those
situations. In milk, there's military
leaders. You take 10 military leaders,
there's all kinds of strengths
and weaknesses different
between all each one of
those 10 and there's all kinds of,
you take 10 civilian leaders and just
all kinds of different strengths and
weaknesses amongst those 10 and if you
put them, if you flip them back and forth,
it doesn't matter if they're still going
to be random strengths and weaknesses.
Some guys are good at
present presenting things.
Some guys are good at simplifying things,
some guys are good at
articulating things and,
and those groups wash out regardless.
There's great military leaders
that aren't very articulate,
but they figured out a way to get done.
There's great a civilian leaders
that aren't very articulate,
but they figured out a way.
There's great military leaders that
are really good at simplifying things.
There's great civilian leaders
that are good at simple.
There's the people that are not good at
that, so they find the correct solution,
the people that will compliment
them as leaders and move forward,
but no huge difference. Actually. There's
no, there's no difference. There's,
there's just, there's good leadership and
there's bad leadership. Yeah, that's it.
Hey Jocko,
love your books and podcasts.
When it comes down to the wire and
you need to make a quick and tactical
decision and Mitt amidst chaos,
how do you keep your head straight?
This is just everyone knows the answer to
this. By now, detach, take a step back,
take a step back off the line,
a step back from the
tactical situation that's going
on. Turn your head, look around,
see what's going on, assess it properly
unemotionally and then make a decision.
That's it.
You got to learn to detach
easily. Money. Next question,
John. It's not easy. It was easy.
People would ask me that question
12 times a day. It is simple.
It is simple but it's definitely not
easy. No it's not. And I'll tell you,
it's not only not easy,
it's almost so hard that you
don't even like see it happening.
It's like you're blind to it.
Most people are blind to it.
That's why it's such a huge advantage
from a leadership perspective.
You can be one inch above everyone else.
You can see infinitely further than
they can cause. Cause let's face it,
they have a limited when when you're,
when you're at one level
and when you're at six feet,
you can see what you can see.
You go to eight feet,
you can see things that they can't see.
They've literally can't see them.
So therefore you know,
things that they don't know and all of
a sudden you seem brilliant because you
can literally see things that they
literally can't see. So take a step back,
turn your head, look around, detached from
your emotions, detached from the chaos.
That's it.
And the emotions.
That's like one of the major
things that's making you blind.
The for sure. Yeah. Whether it's
emotions, whether it's anger,
whether it's frustration, whether
it's panic, whether it's um,
stress.
All those emotions will do have the same
result on you and your decision making,
which is you won't see what's actually
happening. Yeah. Do y'all call,
how do you build a relationship with a
boss that consistently loses his temper
on a regular basis? Stay
calm, don't overreact.
Let them vent to you and don't make a
big deal out of them losing their temper
to just be this, be like, oh,
just absorb it and be like,
hey, it's all good. Boston.
Yup. You know, let them vent and then
when they calm down a little bit,
you don't just don't even don't go like,
man, I'm glad you calm down. No, just,
you know, say, okay, Hey, here's where
we're at with this decision. You know,
I'm going to bring this to the troops or
whatever, you know, just, just be calm.
And then eventually a,
hopefully you get a relationship that's
strong enough that you can actually say
something to him like, hey
man, you know, I know you,
I know things drive you
crazy, but you know, it's you,
it's always a lot better when you're just
kind of calm and everyone kind of has
a lot of respect for
that, you know? But again,
that's when you got to be careful with,
because they might just go,
what are you talking about,
you or know about respect.
They might lose their
separate right there. So yeah,
I'm just going to be calm and not
overreact to absorb that kind of thing.
And the question,
I'm struggling to be an effective leader
because I'm told that I don't have the
right tone.
I'm too direct in course
and I'm not too sure how to fix it. I'd
appreciate any and all help. Thanks man.
You can record yourself while
you're talking to people,
like when you're on the phone with someone
just recorded to take out your, your,
your cell phone and record
and see what you sound like.
Cause you might be surprised
at what you sound like.
A lot of times people don't
realize what they sound like. Um,
you might have to overcompensate for a
little while and be like overly pleasant
and nice to people, which, which
to them might sound like normal,
but to you it'll sound like you're
being just totally over the top. Nice.
Because you're like,
how are you today?
And they're thinking, oh, that's nice.
He's actually having a conversation
with me and knew your mind. You like,
these are just pleasantries I don't think
I should be doing. You know, it's like,
no, just calm down. It's
actually great feedback.
It's awesome that people have actually
told you that you are too direct and too
course.
So what does that mean?
You're offending people if you're
offending people, do they listen to you?
The answer is no.
So how do you not offend people?
And in your mind you're thinking,
Hey, this the way I am, you know,
I'm just one of these people. Let's
direct you. Don't you know, we just,
I just put the word out and it's like, no,
actually all you do is piss people off,
offend them, and now they don't listen
to you. So don't be that person. Yeah.
Let's try and build relationships.
Make that your key goal.
Make your goal not to get
your point across to them,
but to build a relationship with them.
Make that your goal and then the rest
of it will start to come together.
Get you moving in the right direction.
Yeah.
And,
and sometimes I'm not saying
this person is like this,
but sometimes people who are direct in
course like they sort of take pride in it.
Yeah, for sure. So if you can
search your mind and be like, Hey,
am I taking pride in this little
bit? Know that like you're, you're,
you're going full speed in the wrong
direction with that, you know, um,
if that's the case, that makes it a
lot easier. You Go, Yup. Affirmative.
Next question. I served in the Coast
Guard and operate in high risk.
Surf up Beration is where not only do
I have victims in the water who gave a
high risk,
who have high risk of dying,
but also my people and myself have a
high probabilities of being injured or
killed. I enjoy my job thoroughly and
perform on the job, but it's the waiting.
That's brutal. How do you manage
stress? Stress in the off time.
So it's not overwhelming.
Look, you got to train hard. You gotta
be prepared. You've got to rehearse,
you got drill,
worst case scenarios,
you've got to be an awesome physical
condition. You got to do all those things.
You prepare as much as you can.
You can't worry about things
that you can't control.
So the things that you can control,
what can you control?
You can be in good physical shape,
you can prepare for your equipment,
make sure you know how to
operate your equipment.
You can drill worst case scenarios too.
So make sure your team understands the
procedures that you're supposed to do.
So you take control of all the
things that you can control.
You do those to the nth degree.
The things that you can't control you,
you just got to not worry about them
because that's what's, you're actually,
you're actually less prepared because
you're worrying about other things.
You can't sleep because there's a storm
coming and you know that there's gonna
be some rescues. It's like, Hey,
you've prepared, you've trained,
you've got your equipment already. You've,
you've rehearsed with your teammates.
Like that's what we do.
And there's some things that I can't
control and I'm okay with that.
And not to get too crazy,
but like worst case scenario and not to
get too like dark worst case scenario,
what happens? Worst case
scenario, what happens? You Die.
That's the worst case scenario
that happens. Um, okay.
Okay. So you've got your
insurance taken care of,
you've got your Sgli set up,
you know,
you've written letters to your family
to tell them what to do and that you've
had a great job and that you love what
you're doing, what you're doing and,
and that that's the way it goes.
You know,
part of life is death a hundred percent.
Think about that all a hundred percent.
So if you can
compartmentalize the, the things
that you can control and say, okay,
these are the things I've got control of.
And then you look at the
worst case scenario, which
is the worst case scenario.
I mean, I guess the worst
case scenario is like, hey,
if you could one of your
teammates, you know, dies. That's,
that seems to me to always be the
worst thing. Or You die. Well,
what are you going to do so well
to prevent my teammate from dying?
I'm going to train, prepare, do
everything I can in my power.
And one of the things in my power to
do is to not be scared of things that I
can't control or not worried about.
Things that I can't control and then like,
Hey, I could die doing this
job. That could happen,
but do you do about that? You prepare
for it. You, you write your, will,
you make sure that your w your w two or
page two I believe it's called your page
two in the military service records
so that they know what to do with your
finances. You fill out
your Sgli form, you write,
you write a letter to your fans,
friends and family.
That's what you do and then
you go out and you do your job.
The fear,
the fear of death
that you have in your mind is
more likely to cause a problem.
It's more you will have more.
If you're afraid of death,
you're more likely to die than if you
say, you know what? If this happens,
God forbid,
guess what?
I'm living the life I want to live
and I'll, I'm going to die doing this.
It's like that. If you can get
over that hurdle right there,
that's a huge thing and the more
comfortable you are with that,
the less chance of you
actually dying there is because
you won't be scared of it.
You won't be hesitant. You
won't be paranoid, you won't
lose sleep. You'll be like,
okay, so, so just truly
think it like, man, you're,
you're doing an important job. You're
going to try and save people's lives.
There's inherent risk in that,
but it's what you want to do
is what you chose to do theirs.
You deal with that and if
you can get through that,
that's a huge step. Does this
mean you want to die? No,
it doesn't mean that at all.
It doesn't mean that at all.
It doesn't mean that at all, but if
you're like, you know what, I could die.
That's one of the possible outcomes here.
It's highly unlikely,
but it is a possible outcome.
If it happens,
I've lived the best possible way I can.
I've prepared for my family friends
to be taken care of to understand what
happened and I'm, I'm okay with that.
That's, that's my recommendation.
Daca.
I'm a very goal oriented.
I'm very goal oriented.
My friends say that they want me to
achieve this and that yet they still are
vaping, partying, being lazy
and overall don't walk the talk.
I want to be an ATF. Special
tactics, air force, Air Force,
special tactics officer and I don't
have time for those destruction.
How do I get them on track?
Well this is pretty straight
forward one for me. Um,
what I do is I walk the walk and keep
walking and if these guys want to walk the
walk with me,
I'm cool.
But if they want to vape
and party and be lazy,
um, those aren't the kind of guys you
want to round with your team anyways,
you know? So unless they get on the
path that leads to the right place, did,
I mean you can tell him, hey man,
this isn't going to get you there,
but don't spend a bunch of time trying
to pick up and drag people that don't
want to drag themselves.
Not that you go into an organization
like a special tactics in the air force.
You don't want to be
carrying other people.
You don't have to motivate other people.
You want people that want
to do the job themselves.
So don't spend a bunch of time with
these people that don't want to get after
it.
Makes Sense
Jocko,
when things start moving fast and feel
out of control because you're really
getting after it, work, family do
you do to and countless other things.
How do you slow it down and get the
feeling back of being in control?
What you do in this situation is go
harder. You go harder. What you do is,
and this is, think of it like
this, think of it as a sprint.
You're getting bogged down,
there's a bunch of stuff going on.
Grab a hold of a bunch of them
and sprint and get caught up.
That's what you do. You
sprint, you get caught up. Um,
I do that kind of right now
and I didn't start doing that.
I really started having to do these
little sprints that I do sometimes now,
like maybe a year ago where I just have
to just just buckle down for three days
and do nothing but work just that's
it. Nothing but work. Hmm. I'm,
I'm in the middle of one right now.
Like just what,
what I did over the last few days. It's
like I was like work, work and more work.
So it's a sprint but
then you get caught up,
you get things under
control and then you can,
you can go back to a more sustainable
pace cause you can't sprint forever.
You cannot sprint forever factually.
Right. That doesn't work. Yeah.
So if you think you're going
to run alongside of vehicle,
because you can sprint,
that's not going to work.
Eventually the vehicle is going to
outpace you and you're going to be left
behind. So you have to, you have
to choose a race that you can win.
But sometimes just like in a running race,
you got to sprint to get ahead. And then
once you get ahead you can, you know,
you can fall, you can, you can go back
to a sustainable base, but that's,
that's what I do. I go into like a
little period of mass production.
I prefer slow and steady.
Absolutely.
I prefer just to keep on the disciplined
path every day doing what needs to be
done. You know that we talked
about plant and the tree earlier,
like writing a book.
Nothing feels better writing a book.
Then when you look up after,
after a month of writing and you've
got 30,000 words because you wrote a
thousand words a day,
to sit down and write
30,000 words is a gut check.
It's a gut check.
For me it is because I don't enjoy
doing that for long periods of time.
I don't enjoy sitting there typing because
the boards are already pretty much in
my head,
so it's just a manual labor,
but it's not manual labor
where you get to move rocks.
It's a manual later of pecking going
into a keyboard. That's not fun for me.
There's no,
there's zero physical benefit,
but to look up after a month and say,
I've got 30,000 words,
that's almost a book, right? Yeah.
So I prefer to do that,
but sometimes because I've saddled myself
with many different things going on
right now, sometimes I get
behind and I have to sprint.
You have to just say, okay,
you know what,
this is going to suck for three days,
but I'm gonna get back
on track and here we go.
So that's what I do when I started feeling
like other things are kind of getting
the hang me, like, hey man,
maybe you have to for work,
you have to sacrifice Jujitsu for
whatever, two days. You're like, Yup,
I'm not going to train, but um, that's,
it's going to save me a total of five
hours in the next couple of days and I can
get a lot of work done in five hours.
I didn't do Jujitsu yesterday.
Did I want to? Yes, I did. But I said,
okay, I'm going to sprint right now.
I gotta get this other stuff done.
And I had to prioritize. So that's,
that's what you have to do.
And guess what you know?
Then you get through that sprint. Now you
can go back to your sustainable thing,
which is Jujitsu every day. Just work
out every day, which is, you know, right.
You're right every day. Do your
work every day. So try that.
Try just buckling out.
Tell your family,
tell your Jujitsu instructor
and be like, Hey, listen,
I'm gonna be gone for three days.
I got, I got to get caught up.
So standby at, boom. Tell
your family, look, Hey,
I'm sorry for the next three days.
You're not going to hear much from
me because I'm a stay at work late.
I'm going to get a bunch of stuff done
and just sprint hard and give them a
little reward at the end.
Hey,
when I get back on Tuesday or
when I get back on the Friday,
we're going to go out for dinner.
We don't have a good time,
but I've got to sprint. We've got
to get caught up. So there you go.
That's my procedure. Good little tactic
or, yeah, he's a good tactic. Oh,
a little reward.
You like that
the will of the whole deal?
Both of them.
Like basically to make sure that you
communicate with all these people that
might be affected by your thing. Even
like in small ways like how you say, Hey,
I'm going to sprint right now.
You'd be,
oh well I'm sometimes surprised on how
that just that little thing is sole
effective. Like you
know, like I don't know,
I'm going to go to Jujitsu at do weird
different time that maybe my family sort
of depending on me,
not in a big way but just a little bit
depending on me being there. Right.
And I'm going to go to juice instead if
I say a one week before I do that and if
I say, hey, on this day, you know, like
I understand, hey, usually I'm here,
I dig it,
but hey,
I'm going to go this day of this training
just kind of means a lot to me this
day and time, whatever. A
week before heads up. They
love it, love night into him,
tried to do it the hour
before versus the week before,
night and day one situation.
It's like yes, oh we got
your back, what we'll do it.
And the other one is like disdain.
Guess what?
My wife thinks what she thinks I'm going
to Jiu Jitsu every day and I am just
like,
so I'm sure at some point
to her if I'm ever like, oh
you know, she'll be like,
oh you didn't leave yet. I'm like, no, I'm
actually working. It's, she'll be like,
oh okay. That's what she
realized. I got some work to do,
Matt not, but that's a good tip.
That's good to remember it, you know,
cause it's easy to get caught up in
like hey this is me and my sprint.
I'm the one going to have to buckle
down, you know, sort of thing.
So it kind of maybe gets in
the way of you thinking like,
hey it's for other people too.
You know what I'm saying?
And then that that additional one where
it's I can when I'm done and you've got
another reward. Cause then
if you communicate they don't
need the reward. I mean,
you know, it depends on who
it is, but typically it would,
it would make sense for them not to
need the reward because we're all good
scenario. Don't do it
too much. They expect it,
but that's a good to, I think
that's good. I'm going to,
I'm going to put down into
rotation. Next question. Hey Jocko,
a lot of respect for you and your work.
I have a question.
How do you draw the line between doing
things you're uncomfortable with to
develop and just torturing
yourself unnecessarily?
Who's pretty?
It's pretty straight forward question
actually in a pretty straightforward
answer. Does it benefit you
or not? Does it benefit you?
And,
and there is some level of torture that
benefits you because it just keeps you
mentally and physically tougher.
So there is benefit to
to some level of torture,
right?
There's also a level of torture that
is not beneficial for you. Actually.
It takes you backwards and
it's going to injure you.
It's going to break you down,
it's going to break you down mentally.
It's going to break you down physically.
There's times like I've talked about this,
like there's times when I've gotten
on a plane where I get on a plane,
this is what I know. I'm just done
training, which is I get on a plane and I,
cause normally on a plane I can
like really hammer out some work.
I can get a podcast,
I can read a book.
I could just really go
hard because there's no,
I don't sign up for Wifi on the planes.
I just do work.
And um, when I get on a
plane and I'm just like, Ugh,
I'm going to watch him,
I'm going to go into this thing and watch.
And I remember the last time I did,
I watched zoo lander. Yeah man.
Which is a funny movie,
but there's No v zero positive benefit
to my humanity by watching Zealander.
But that's, that's it. So,
so I just like, okay, mentally
need to dam break, you know.
And same thing with physical,
like there's times where you're
physically like there's times,
this is interesting one,
when you're training Jujitsu,
if I have an injury that's recovering
and let's say normally I do eight rounds,
10 rounds,
when I have an injury that's recovering,
I have to have the discipline to say,
you know what,
I'm only doing four rounds today because
when you get to the fifth, six round,
I'm tired. I'm making mistakes.
Seventh, eighth round,
now I'm actually going
to get injured again,
so I want to recover from the
injury, so I take some, I take law.
I have to have the discipline to say no
because the lack of discipline says I'm
just going to train more obscure to train
harder and sometimes you have to take
a little,
a little bit of a breather
and so if you're doing
something that's uncomfortable
but it's making you stronger or
smarter or faster, yeah, that's good.
If you're doing something
that's uncomfortable and
it's not beneficial to you,
then that's not smart to do except for
the occasional gut check, which is, hey,
this is just going to suck.
I mean this is just going to suck
and I'm going to do it anyways. Yeah.
And that's fine.
You're kind of different than people
in with the concept that you're talking
about it. I think. Yeah, that's
universal with just good, like, you know,
you talk about like going on the plane,
right? Even like the way you're like,
that is no good for humanity.
Well you know,
I know that was like a
joking way of putting it,
but the thing is that is good for
you and it's what is their lender,
zoo lander,
whatever you or something that
that's like not work cause it's like,
you know, compared to a workout,
Rob Jones does this a lot. He'll compare
it to like lifting weights or workout,
which is good. I think I put near
perfect analogy, the working out thing,
it's, it's essentially just your
rest between sets. That's all it is.
So if it's like, yeah, you don't
get rest between sets. Oh yeah.
See how much weight you can lift
then probably not that much.
But there's a difference between resting
for like two minutes between your sets
and then resting one day. Yeah,
I agree. Sometimes though,
sometimes you can say, oh, I need a rest,
but you don't really know what I mean.
Yeah. You gotta be careful of
that. Sometimes you got to go, oh,
this is just torture Straw.
I don't want to do it.
But you're really just being mentally
weak. Right. So you have to be aware.
You have to do things that
suck sometimes. Yeah, for sure.
Some workouts just suck and
they're awful and their torture,
but they make you stronger, they make you
better, and they make you tougher. Yeah.
So you do them. Yeah. So it
perfect in the, if you want
to do the workout analogy,
right, where you're like, okay, so there's
those, those two dichotomies, if you will.
So it's like, okay, rest between
sets. Cool. I dig it. You do work,
and then you rest between sets.
That's the whole thing, right. Format.
But you're like, okay, I,
if I need two minutes of rest in between
my sets for this specific workout for
this specific outcome or results
from the workout, then boom.
That's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna rest for two minutes.
So there's differences in that case,
there's a difference between
rescuing two minutes and then rescue,
resting 15 minutes. You don't need all
that rest. Now you're just cruising.
Now you're just avoiding the next set
or putting it off or doing whatever.
There's a difference.
But on the other side,
the more extreme side of the spectrum,
the workout can be like not two
minutes rest of the workout.
The whole workout could last two
hours long. No rest between sets.
That's the workout.
But when the workout's done,
you still got to rest and
recover from that workout.
So just cause you don't have a set
amount of sets in in your work day to day
still doesn't mean you need that rest
between sets or at the very least rest
between work. And one thing that
I got used to in the military,
and I see it in companies all the time,
like I could work 24 hours a day,
seven days a week and never stop
and never get everything done. Yeah.
That's something to think about. So
then you have to say to yourself, well,
how productive I going to be and what's
important and what's not important.
And you got to make sure that you get,
you're right. If you take no rest,
you won't be able to function properly.
And for me,
like I could write 24 hours a day and
not write all the books I want to write.
I could do Jujitsu 24 hours a day
and not get as good as I want to get.
I could work out 24 hours a day and
not get as strong as I want to get.
So you have to figure out how to balance
all those different items together to
figure out like,
okay,
what is an acceptable level at
each one of these components? Yeah.
And it's going to take kind of identifying
the results that you want that are
acceptable to you. You know?
So, yeah, like a little, what
do you call it? You know,
like Nascar, right? Right.
If watch streets of thunder on another
one with Tom Cruise that he's a NASCAR
something offender days
of thunder. Okay. Anyway,
he's like racing
and he's like, Hey, you
got to do a pit stop.
Everybody got to do a pit stop.
But it seems weird,
you know when you're like racing and
you're like, Hey, I'm ahead of everybody.
I'm not going to stop right
now. I'm word, you know.
But I bet your wheels are going to fall
off bell. So you got a pitstop sometimes.
Sure. Watch them, Zoolander, whatever.
And then when you're done you can be way
more productive because those tires are
new now they can fly or on
the track grip everything.
So what I'm saying quicker. So that's
part of the game. That's what I'm saying.
Next question.
How does the introduction you gave to
Mike in the equipment room square with
extreme ownership?
No judgment.
Oh yeah.
So Mike Cirelli when Mike's really came
into task and your bruiser because his
other,
his other tasks and it had had some
leadership issues and Mike was sort of the
collateral damage in that whole thing.
And so they moved him from that task unit,
which was Task Unit Charlie
into tasking at bruiser.
And when he came in, I brought him into
the equipment room at seal team three,
which is where I would counsel my
junior officers because there was,
there was construction going on at seal
team three at the time and there's no
ceilings so everyone could
hear you in your office.
And so I would go into this equipment
room and brief guys if need be.
And I just brought Mike's Rolling
in there and I had uh, uh,
counseling letter for him to sign and
it said there's no drama in task unit.
Bruiser don't bring any into it.
And that's it. It was like
really straight forward. I don't,
I'd have to ask him if he still has it,
but I don't know why this person thinks
that that doesn't square with the
extreme ownership as far as I'm concerned.
That is,
I had a guy that was coming into a unit
that had been together for seven or
eight months, gone through workup and
ready, getting ready for deployment at an,
I just had to take ownership of the fact
that I had a guy that was showing up
that I didn't know.
I did get feedback,
I got feedback from multiple people,
multiple sources,
and my bro source was like,
Hey Sorelli,
he's fucking good to go. And I was like,
okay, cool. So I knew he was good to go,
but still I wanted to set the,
the expectation right for him
so that he knew like, like man,
he might think that that was his
first task. It, he was with, you know,
he might think this is the way it is.
It's like, no, that's not the way it is.
So for me it was just, hey, we're
just, we're just taking ownership.
But for me it was, hey, I'm just
gonna take ownership of this,
make sure he knows what's going on,
make sure we understand the expectations,
make sure that we're not going to have
any drama in here because we don't have
any drama. There's no drama.
Like, we have problems we solve.
We don't backstab each other and telling
each other and stab each other in the
back. No, we have a problem.
We get together, we solve the
problem. That's how it is.
And so that's all, you know. No. Uh,
I don't even think that's a, I'm, I'm,
I'm not even quite sure.
I'd have to get more details
on this question to figure
out why that didn't seem
like the right thing to do.
From my perspective. It was,
you know, it's great when you, when you
have somebody come on board and they go,
hey man, here's the expectations
that are going on. Boom. Yeah.
Maybe cause that was
before he did anything.
It's not like he did something and
then you were like, just showed up.
You're bringing drama. Don't do that
here. It wasn't that. It was like, man,
we don't have drama here. Right.
Don't bring any in here. Yeah.
You're good with that. And Mike's really
said Roger that sir. Yeah. Makes Sense.
Yeah, of course. And you how much
drama he brought in zero. Yeah.
Yeah. So in a way, I mean, I don't
know, looking at it from the outside,
it seems like that was, you know, the,
the, the essence of extreme ownership,
some anticipated problems. I'm going
to do everything to mitigate, you know,
whatever,
all these things and I'm going to go a
preempted problem solving mode tactfully.
Yeah. You know, when you're
wearing, you know, in the
locker room or whatever. Yeah.
It wasn't even like I was like,
you better not,
it didn't even accuse him of
anything you don't punish checks for.
Literally said there's no drama
here. Yeah. Don't bring any,
I didn't say like you, we know. You know,
I think I'd like to point my finger now.
It was like, hey man, hey.
Cause in my mind I'm thinking,
you know what I'm thinking in my mind,
hey,
you got a prior enlisted marine
that's going to be in my task unit.
I got another body and he's an
experienced guy with, you know.
Yeah. That was, I was, yeah, I was
totally stoked, man. Yeah, yeah.
No factor. We got time
for one more man. Sure.
How do you stay on the warpath when
everything seems to be going wrong?
Good question. Can you think? That's
a good question. Well, here's,
here's what I think is
strange about that question.
It's sort of like the question I just
answered about like sprinting. Yeah.
It's easy to, when things are going right,
it's easy to stay on the warpath, right?
You don't even need to be on the warpath
when things are going great because
everything's happy. There's no war going
on. You're at peace. People are, you know,
delivering food to you and
you're getting a massage. Yeah.
There's no, there's no,
you're not like, oh,
I need to be on the warpath right now
while I'm getting a back massage while I'm
getting food delivered. To
me, that's not happening.
When the actual time that you need to
go on the warpath and you need to go
harder on the warpath is when
things are going wrong, wrong.
That's when you need to dig deeper.
That's when you need to,
that's when the whole
like idea of saying good.
That's when it happens.
When things are actually,
when you're getting tested by the world,
that's when you want to do it.
So when you get tested by the world,
that's when you get the opportunity
to show the world what's your made of.
That's where you get to say,
bring it on,
bring it on. Oh, things are
going wrong. Bring it on.
I actually look forward to that.
Yeah,
because this is when I get
to exercise my discipline.
This is when I get to show the discipline.
I get to put the discipline to work.
It's the moment I have been
waiting for because let's face it,
if things were easy, then I could
just sit around and slack off.
Right. That's what, that's what
could happen. When things are easy,
when things are going right, that's when
you actually can slack off a little bit.
Cause things going. Right.
I don't recommend it.
I recommend actually when things
are going right, you go hard.
But when things are going wrong,
you need to go even harder.
So if everything's going wrong,
it doesn't matter to me
because I'm on the path.
I'm going to stay on the path on the
warpath and when to get my situation
rectified. Stat, get some.
All right. That's like two
hours or something right now.
So let's, um, I don't know,
speaking of the war path,
the path, yes. Yes. How could
we get people to, you know,
how could we assist with
people being on the ward?
Step one did you do to nothing?
Yeah man.
That's step one.
Straight up men will make depends
on where you are to begin with.
So let's face it anyway. It's
all you need. Your, your g right?
No need to ask anymore.
Get origin origin main.com hundred
percent a hundred percent made in America.
Yes.
The 200% geared g to get the G to
get and also 100% made in America.
Made in America from the dirt to the top.
Straight up. Yeah, because let's face
it from the top soil to the GE top.
Top. Slow to the top of
the Geek. Yeah. Fully.
And for those who care about
the aesthetics of Biggie,
these, this theoretics
are, how should I say,
made specifically for Jujitsu for sure.
But I did it.
Two people budget is of people.
Yes, but they're like the cut.
You know how you'd like cut like Fords.
You did too. You see what I'm saying?
And they look dope too, by the way, if
you care about that kind of stuff. Yeah.
Awesome. Do you want to make like
you don't care but you care? No,
I w I am and always have been
impressed by specifically dragon.
We've come on. Yeah, that'd be a
dragon. The or you're not like,
like I still am impressed it is.
When you see or have you
seen the machine that they,
that they figure out how to weave
that thing. It's like, yeah,
it's in Pete's office and
it's like, uh, it's the, I'll,
I'll have Pete post a picture of it,
but it's still,
it looks like a mechanical thing from
from 1898 I batches from 1930 I bet you
the thing is actually from 1930 we'll
have to ask Pete what year it is,
but that's the actual thing. It's the
old school thing that you figure out.
You put your program is the word,
but it's nothing.
There's nothing digital
about this program.
What the fabric is going to look like
from this machine. It's a freaking,
it's cool. Anyways. Yeah,
so that's the dragon.
We've also rash guards
also 100% made in America.
Um, tee shirts, other things,
some cool stuff on that.
Supplements as well. Yeah. Yeah. And um,
supplements for your joints,
a four,
you're being being as a human.
Yes.
And for your operational capabilities?
So joint warfare for your joints,
Krill oil for your being and joined and
joints discipline for your operational
capability,
lift,
lift your cognitive and
your physical capabilities.
And then of course we got that milk,
some additional protein for that one.
I had a big milkshake put dark
chocolate in it by the way.
You said that on the last podcast
again? Yes. And I put a dark, dark time.
How was it outstanding with what
flavor? Milk, peanut butter chocolate.
Is that your go to currently?
It is. It was the main, it
is for me too. Yeah. So it,
it's in a rotation in and it's
all based on like how I feel.
I'm just going to tell you I'm,
I probably have had peanut
butter six times in a row.
Yeah. Which it used to be not happening.
It would be mint six times in a row.
And then right now I'm just so down with
that peanut butter peanut butter train
situation
and these supplements overall,
especially the joint ones like Mulkey,
it's easy. It's like a kind of,
it just me alone with my thoughts. I'm
like, this is kind of a glamorous one.
The protein, hell yeah, my
muscles. But the joint warfare,
they don't get like the glamour.
Here's what,
here's what one of my buddies
was telling me yesterday,
one of my brethren the seals was,
is using vanilla gorilla and
he's like, um, he's like,
I'm putting it in everything.
Everything. He makes coffee,
boom, vanilla, the teak. Boom.
Yeah. I don't know about tea,
but his main thing was coffee.
These putting in his coffee and
he said it's like a sweetener,
but obviously it's not right. It's not
bad for you. Yeah, it is Wheaton there.
Cause he was, he was,
you know when you're talking to people
and they get like the, the like little,
the little kid look. Yeah, he had
that. He's not going to have to put,
I put the vanilla gorilla
there and I hate it with the,
I could say he was getting fired up when
he said he ate it with the blenders was
like that's
it. The blender. The one. Yeah. So
technically I do the same thing,
but I put the coffee in, it's like a
lower and express or whatever in the milk.
Oh. So it's like a
milkshake. But same deal by,
I'm sure the ratios are different in
like coffee. It is. And that's the thing.
It is. So if you, if you, uh,
like like coffee, ice cream,
you know, like that kind of stuff. We're
a coffee ice cream and like black coffee.
Those are two different experiences
for sure. So coffee, ice cream,
that's a delicious flavor when it's like,
so it's kind of the
same deal with them all.
Speaking of delicious strawberry and
chocolate warrior kid milk for your
children.
I this,
this could get some kind of, uh, you know,
I'm not going to put myself
in for a Nobel peace prize,
but like,
hey,
we are helping the children
of the world in a big way.
Yeah. With strawberry and
chocolate warrior good milk,
because there's no other thing that
you're just as a kid, as a kid,
you're about that little snickers bar
hitter right now are these bad snacks in
the snack you hitters,
right? Sure. The right,
I'll check with Theo Vaughn on that one
because he understands a hinders better
than me,
but if you can give your kid a
strawberry or chocolate milk heater,
they're just going to go smoke and
they're going to get stronger. Yup.
Literally healthier. Really. I told
Pete, I said on the warrior kid podcasts,
that warrior kid Molko will
make you stronger and he's like,
I don't know if you can legally
make that claim. I'm like, well,
it's already been said and it's straight
up. How can you wait? How can you not?
How can that not be legally made?
Because does protein rebuild your muscles?
Answer. Yes it does. Warrior could
milk have protein in it? Yes.
I guess we got to get the
kids to Jack Steele too
or just grow up as a kid. Healthy. Yeah.
You'll get stronger as a kid growing up.
You don't have to Jack,
so we are technically and
legally authorized to say
to the children of the world
warrior kid milk will make you stronger
if I get the Nobel prize for that.
You get a Nobel prize for helping
children around the world. Yes.
Okay then I deserve it.
There you go.
Not to go too deep into the whole
thing about getting stronger,
like if you make the claim that
something's going to make you stronger.
I think that is fine like legally because
legally you can't like diagnose it
wasn't there. There are certain,
there's a list of things you can do.
You can't diagnose,
you can't oh treat.
Do you know if their specific kind of,
they're more medic medically
based and I think, but I know,
well the only thing that we really,
the only claim that we make,
which is scientifically proven is the,
is the
deadlift capabilities. Have you
drank Jocko white tea? Is 8,000 yeah.
Which I mean obviously
everyone's good line.
No one's going to argue with that
one. Nope. Cause that's just facts.
So if you want some of the,
if you want some Jocko white tea
because you need a bigger deadlift,
which you probably do. Yeah. Then
you can get that from Amazon.
Well, the cans from Amazon,
you can get it everywhere.
Everywhere. Meaning online. Just go online
man. Okay. Jocko white tea on the store.
Okay. There you go. On, on
what store? Jocko store.
Chuck was a store called Jocko store.
And the website is
[inaudible] dot com online.
Did you see the website for origin?
Origin? The industry? Yeah. Oh yeah.
For all the same. The Jocko, uh, joint
warfare Moke, the gies, the rash guard,
the origin stuff is all@originmain.com.
I did say it, but you know,
that's a little reminder.
Yeah. But Jocko white tea,
okay.
Is Everywhere.
Including Jocko,
store.com also [inaudible] dot com is
where you can get your shirts when you're
representing on the path. See? And
that's a big part of being on the path.
Actually. That's a good psychological
and physical in my experience.
I like the, I don't even know what
you're going to say about it. No.
You're going to say what helps
you stay on the path as well,
saying you're not going to eat a
doughnut while you're wearing a disc.
Nichols freedom tee shirts. That's
physically impossible. I think so.
Yes. You'll be like, you'll,
you'll be like the exorcist.
You just won't be able to stop yourself
from throwing the doughnut box. Yeah.
In the garbage can. You know
what's weird and I'm being serious.
It's like now and me safe bow.
Like I can't eat a donut. Even
if I'm by myself. Like I can't,
like it's, it's embedded already
because of those of the path. Yeah.
It's a,
it prevents me physically from eating.
The only donut I could eat as one that is,
is an actual piece of steak cut into
a circle with a piece missing from the
middle. Yeah. I might do that. Maybe I'm
hugging me like here's my steak donut.
Well, to get some, well,
here's the thing though.
There's such thing as like
little protein donuts. Yeah.
But if you look at the ingredients,
I don't know.
That's really what it feels like.
A Paleo pro ino healthy.
When people make Paleo stuff,
it's like kind of solid. Okay.
Why not just shape it like a stick?
Really putting it into a
donuts. Yes. This scenario.
That's just cause I think that's it.
I think that's the thing.
It's like the fact that
it's a donut Kinda is.
That's what kind of creates the little
thing in my, in my brain. Anyway. Anyway,
back to the storage.
I'll store hoodies on their shirts,
on their hats on there. A lot of cool
stuff on there if you want to represent,
if going to represent in the wild.
Okay.
Jocko stored up. Come grab something.
He'd be on the DEF core path
also. Okay. We talked about
Jack White Tea obviously.
Also you are subscribed to the
podcast if you haven't already.
That'll kind of keep
you in tune so to speak.
Seems obvious I guess, but it doesn't
seem like a small thing, but hey,
it's good and subscribe. Stay tuned. Stay
in touch on iTunes, stitcher, Google play.
You know, anywhere where you listened
to your podcast quits. Subscribe.
Also the worry,
your kid podcasts.
Is the warrior kid Parcast
better than Jocko podcast?
I personally don't think so.
At the end of the day,
what he say net union say men that
you've heard that expression net net.
My brother says that all the time anyway.
Net Net.
I liked the Jocko podcast
better. Here's the thing. No,
it's not like just cut and
dry like legit competition.
Yeah.
And here's the thing.
If you were to observe them
from a completely unbiased,
you probably don't like the warrior
could podcast because you're not in it.
I can't creek in rebuttal my stuff.
Maybe here's the thing may be here,
but here's the no, no, the,
here's the, here's the part that
kind of kind of what he sort of like,
he's like a rebuttal to my own opinion.
Work at podcasts.
Every single one of those was,
was like
90 like out to 85 to 100% impactful.
Like every little thing like that felt
like applied to me where I can like
whether it be an idea, not talking about
your daughter. No, you applied to you.
To me directly. Here's the
thing. Some things yesterday,
six years old or whatever
you are. Yeah. Yes, but,
and I'm not saying it doesn't apply
to my daughter. I'm not saying that.
I'm saying it applies to me directly,
whether it be me in my own life or me,
how I'm going to deal with my daughter
now or my son or whatever hunted.
Like all of the things pretty much
like that's kind of the, so net net.
Yeah, Jocko podcasts. Sure.
I like better maybe because there's kind
of more more thing. I don't know why,
but that's my answer.
But I will say that maybe then
maybe you might be right,
but maybe because there's so there's
not as many where your kid maybe, yeah,
maybe I need more. I need more to shift
over to two for that to be better.
I Dunno. Maybe either way. That's on
Itunes, stitcher. Oh yeah. That's on,
that's a podcast as well
that you subscribe to.
Also Youtube is a where you can
do to, well there's word, yeah,
speaking to Youtube. There's the
Jocko podcast channel on Youtube.
There's warrior kid podcast on Youtube,
which we separated so that your child
won't be watching warrior King podcast and
then all of a sudden have the rape of
Dan King podcasts creep into their zone.
Right. So he separated them,
but they're both up there.
They're both available.
And also on the Jocko podcast,
that's where echo puts up videos of with,
with enhancements to them that make them
make the message more impactful in his
opinion. Well, hopefully we'll say hope.
Like I said though, uh, the
Mikey and the dragons video,
which has moved to the top slot
in my opinion for your video.
So which is a bold statement.
Cool. Yeah. It's a bold statement.
People have got tears in their eyes from
a two minute video about a kid's book.
That's pretty impressive.
Yeah. Well I do have to say I, I even had
tears in my eyes. He was the thing nuts.
I for Real, and I'm not going
to be local humble with that.
I don't think it's necessarily because
of me making the video because like,
well I dunno, I'm only speaking
for myself where Kay. So the,
the king died. This is a story within a
story. It's a story of a story in a story.
So there's like three layers there.
But so the idea of the king dying and
then the kid being like young and having
this big responsibility heaped
on his shoulders, shoulders,
and him being scared for some reason
on a night, just get, just play, call,
whatever about that was, I don't
know, sensitive about that can stuff.
So when it's like you explaining it and
you said like you're not being off tough
Jocko,
you know,
it seems saying like you're doing
it like appropriately seems sane.
And then so it's like that. That's really
what kind of affected me. And I think,
sure,
I laid it out in a way where it's like
kind of delivered in the appropriate way.
But is it,
is it,
oh, I was going to ask if it was more
impactful because you and I know the whole
story, but people that don't know the
whole story that didn't have the book yet,
we're like, Ooh my God, Eh. Cause cause
we know the whole story. It's like,
oh that's cool. But then
people that didn't know the
whole story, we're just like,
ah,
you know what?
Actually no another thing,
because jade said the same thing and he
didn't read the whole story and he and
he actually had little tears
in his eyes. He's like, yeah,
I have tears in my eyes
because I don't know why.
Like trying to act like it's
just so confusing, you know?
But meanwhile he's all
like being all anymore.
Yeah. I saw what went on. So that's
the, uh, that's the youtube channel.
You can subscribe to that. That'd be cool.
We'd appreciate it and all that stuff.
Plus you can leave. The big thing about
if you subscribe to the Youtube Channel,
you need to comment about echo because
the only compensation that echo receives
for participation in this podcast is
being able to read the youtube comments
that say echo is sold.
So you go on Youtube, subscribe,
and then right echo is yoked,
echo is jacked,
echo is looking massive,
all that kind of stuff because
that way it'll be happy.
I can just pay him with that.
That's what gets paid with.
Yeah, that's, that's the worst idea
I've ever heard. It's not that bad,
but nonetheless, but you do like
it nonetheless. You pointed it out.
Did. Yes, he did. When you
were like, you were like, oh,
there's always someone that says, I
Look Jack. I never said that anyway.
Anyway, psychological warfare.
Okay. If you didn't know
what that is, is what it is.
It's an album with tracks.
It's on iTunes and Amazon
music and stuffs in album matrax Jocko
saying, helping you, us, he's helping us.
That's what he's doing.
Jock was helping us through moments of
weakness when they arise and they'll rice,
you can't sprint forever
and you,
you might instead of taking appropriate
action when you realize you can't print
forever, sometimes you might want to
take a little bit more rest between sets.
You don't have to but so
should it too much rest.
You might want to yes,
exactly right.
And you will not ever look checked
if you're taking between sets.
So get psychological MP3. Yes.
Yes.
And you'll get past those,
those moments cause Jack will just help
me through it just by telling you that's
the thing.
It's like a little spot,
you know when you're slacking a little
spot in reference to weightlifting.
Yeah. If that's the analogy
someone's trying to lift
and they can't quite get it.
And so they help you lift it a
little bit and give it a little spot.
But the roof case weightlifting, yes.
But in this case, how you get jacked
his case instead of weights,
it's your slacker, um,
weakness that might come. I'm not saying
we're all week, but sometimes some of us,
a lot of us are sometimes anyway,
Jack was there for eight. Boom.
Psychological warfare.
Also if your workouts boring,
even if it's not boring, get more
fitness gear. So I incorporated, okay,
get it from on it.
Write on it.com/jocko fitness gear,
rope battle ropes, rings,
kettle bells. Of course.
To me,
if you don't have the kettle bells,
I feel like there's like one little
element, big, small, I don't know,
depends on who you are. But there's one
little element of life that's missing,
that's my opinion. But when I got the
rings that changed my whole workup.
So what I do, what I do, you know the like
you do a bunch of cool stuff on rings.
I, I only do a handful of actually not
even a handful, like two or three things.
One of the main ones are like, you know,
when you, I make them go super low.
Like maybe waste, maybe handstand
pushups in him. No, Bruh.
I'm still a beginner at
the rings, but so, uh,
hold them in front of me and then I'll do,
it's kind of like an ab roller kind of
thing. One arm at a time or both arms?
Both arms. And then sometimes I'll
go like wide and narrow, whatever.
So I'll do those. I'll do like sets
of 10 and you can adjust how high.
So how hard and easier it is.
Whatever kilometer off the ground
you're going to go full extension.
You can get there. I'm going to get there
nonetheless, between every exercise,
uh, actually not between
every set you do a set of 10,
that's like the workout because it's
not super exhausting to do it, you know?
So it's like an active rest.
It's Goodman.
I think it'll take your like workout
to the next of all does a thing.
People say that trigger to the next cell.
That doesn't even mean anything.
Even if it doesn't take it. If it
takes us, will it help you get jack,
let me briefly explain
what that means to the next level.
So like when you do, I don't know,
dead lifts or odd or no shoulder
press or something, like when your
curls, all victim curls and tricep
extension, when you do these things,
you're like sense your like
core or whatever is stronger.
And this is just what I'm like,
you feel when your core is strong,
it feels like you have way better balance.
You have like way better control of,
of the weights. He gets
stronger overall. Boom. Just,
just from rinks shit. Anyway. Yeah.
Anyway, [inaudible] dot com that's,
that's where you get all this cool stuff.
If you want to get your mind smarter
and tougher and get
your brain more jacked,
you want to do your brain more
jacked. Uh, we've got some books, uh,
Mike in the dragons that is out there
are more being printed at this time.
I'm printing as many as humanly possible.
Order it immediately so that I
know and I can get it to you. Um,
it's common. So it's, we've,
we've shipped out some,
we got some more coming in right now,
so yeah, if you haven't ordered it,
ordered it yet, then order it now. Uh,
the feedback is awesome right now and
thank you for posting the reviews on
Amazon.
That's so cool to read and see little
pictures of kids reading the book and I'm
just super stoked on that book,
so thank you for that and weigh the
warrior kid for the kids. I don't know,
maybe just a little bit older.
That's a book about getting on the path
for kids and it's going to help them in
every possible element of their
life that I can think of right now.
It will. It will. It will help
them. Don't make them smarter.
It will make them work harder.
It'll make them understand
discipline will make them stronger.
It'll just help them across the board.
That's the way the warrior kid and in
the follow on mission of the follow on
book to that is where the
warrior kid marks mission.
The next is the discipline equals field.
The discipline equals
freedom field manual,
which is a book about how to get
after it. Yeah, they'll book.
It's the book about how to get it isn't,
it is not a throwaway book
by any stretch. No, it is.
How would you describe it? Manual. It's
a manual, but I mean instrument. No.
What's the word you used
earlier? Aesthetically.
Aesthetically. Aesthetically.
Could you possibly look,
just look on the external part.
Just the cover of the field manual and
think maybe I'll do a little extra work
today. Yes. It's entirely possible.
Yeah, fully. And he was, you know
what's in it? Yeah. Get after it.
Material the, well, and I
was thinking about this too,
not extensive thought,
but there's an audio version of
this true cure, which is cool.
Which is good. But it's Kinda like one
of those things where you kind of like,
man, I kind of want the
physical book. Even if I'm,
if I'm more of an book person,
I, I want that physical book
because of its aesthetics heavy.
It's heavy. It has black pages. Like
let's just put it to you that, well,
let's just start with that. Have you
ever seen a book with blank pages? No.
You haven't? No. Get to get
the field manual right there.
If you do want the audio version than
it's on iTunes, Amazon music, Google play.
It's not on audible because I wanted
you to be able to use it as a alarm.
Sure. Some of those
things, little warnings,
the tracks ready to be played at a
moment's notice. And that's the thing too,
like if you timed,
if you time,
if you set up a timer where when you
were going to lunch sugarcoated lies,
plate it, keeping check
real men. Perfect example.
Because the thing is like some of these
chapters or whatever you're going to
identify with more than let's
say the next chapter, you know,
especially like if you like
donuts or make streets of sorts,
you know the sugar could lies one.
You're going to be referencing that one
a little bit more, right. So it's like,
okay. You know, so you have
that option now. That's good.
And put it on the timer as
good check. Oh, uh, yeah. The,
the next book is that,
I'll talk about two books together.
Extreme ownership and
dichotomy of leadership.
These are two books about the
lessons learned on the battlefield.
Myself and Leif Babin wrote the books,
he was in task unit bruiser as
the Charlie platoon commander.
And we took the lessons that we learned
over there, we brought them back,
we started teaching them to the seals
that were getting ready to deploy and we
wrote extreme ownership when we got out
and started working with companies and
saw that all the lessons that we learned
transferred to the civilian sector.
And then we wrote the dichotomy
of leadership as a follow on book,
which some people are saying is better.
I don't know which one is better, but I
do know that they will make you better.
They will make you a better leader.
So check those out.
Extreme ownership dichotomy of leadership.
Mikey and the dragon's way,
the warrior kid, Mark's mission and
discipline equals freedom field manual.
You can get your brain jacked,
which is the word of the day.
Echo, uh, echelon front. That's
a leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
So if you have a team,
if you have a company,
if you have a business and you want to
get your leadership aligned and you want
to get them functioning
at the highest level,
you can go to echelon front.com.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do.
We've got the muster coming in 2019
Chicago and Denver and we're also doing
Sydney, so checkout extreme
ownership.com for details on that.
All of the past musters have sold out
these musters we'll sell out as well.
So try and get an early
so that you can come.
We actually turned people away.
We turned to a pretty good
number of people away from
musters zero zero seven in
Francisco in that
that doesn't feel good.
You feel kind of bad.
So try and register early for that.
And then of course f Overwatch.
This is where we are taking people
from our old community in the Spec ops,
special operations community and the
combat aviation community folks that were
leaders and tested as leaders on the
battlefield and now we are taking those
tried and tested leaders and placing
them into civilian organizations to help
the leadership in those companies
and teams. You can go to eff,
overwatch.com if you're either a vet
that is looking for your next mission or
you're a company looking for
your next high level leader
and if you have more questions
or you have answers for, for us,
we are available on the
Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on Facebook.
Facebook echo is at echocharles and I
am at jockowillink and thanks to all the
military folks out there
that are protecting us from
evil around the globe and
thanks to police, law enforcement,
firefighters, paramedics, EMT,
correctional officer's border patrol,
and all first responders.
Thanks for holding the line 24 hours
a day here on the home front and to
everyone else out there,
thank you for your questions.
But as I said earlier,
most of these questions you
already know the answers to
you already know the right thing to do.
You already know what
you're supposed to do.
You already know how to get on the
war path and stay on the war path.
It's by getting out there every single day
and getting after it.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.